resident sleeper leute danke für den sub michael fünf spieljahren 14 monate
super subscription hier resident sleeper ich sag's euch hyper resident sleep und
auch nicht alle am start hier wieder michael fünf spieljahren ist da der fips ist da
dayscode laupitin das hört sich an wie ein medikament vielleicht ist es ja auch
keine ahnung der dev operator fake net renex dennis ke dom leubel mario xcb synaptics
deadpie korius maxi mitzar der kalf ist auch am start jawoll jetzt sind sie alle am start
leute ich muss euch sagen der youtube algorithm
versagt heute komplett bei mir es wird nur mist angezeigt also wirklich youtube
algorithmus ist heute eher so ist wirklich nur mist drin heißt wenn ihr irgendwelche
guten videos habt die wir gucken können dann sagt bescheid ich habe einen neuen job nice
pock was denn freedom phone ist kein escape was ist denn das was was ist denn das freedom
phone jetzt schon wieder okay freedom phone ist das klingt
nach reminds me of nadine
der gopro fps 4
das habe ich das habe ich offen schon stimmt level cap
es gibt denn was zum beginn des level cap dann wiederammentort battlefield 2042 aha
aha was what the seriously thoughpop
Sie denn? Da bin ich mal gespannt. Ich wette,
mir ist es der gleiche Krempel, den sie uns auch schon
erzählt haben, bloß noch mal etwas
ja, weiter
ausgebreitet
alles.
Wahrscheinlich ist da überhaupt nichts neu.
Das BDO, ne.
Als Software Engineer,
Solution Architekt bei einem
Consultant-Unternehmen.
Big Brain Time.
Du kannst da Zertifikate machen, Pock.
Welche Zertifikate? Ach so!
Ach so, Zertifikat. Ich habe jetzt
an Let's Encrypt oder so gedacht. Hä?
Warum geht das bloß freitags? Ach, jetzt
verstehe ich es. Wie findest du das?
Was für ein Ding? Was ist? Ich habe
keine Ahnung, was das ist. Ich habe
absolut keine Ahnung. Ah, das ist ein Elektrofahrrad.
Okay, kann
ich nichts zu sagen. Keine Ahnung.
Der Cutebot ist
eh ein bisschen broken in letzter Zeit.
Das liegt aber wahrscheinlich
am Cutebot selber.
Da kann man, denke ich mal, nicht viel machen. Die hat ja
auch in den letzten Tagen die Video,
sag ich schon, die. Nur weil
der Cutebot einen
weiblichen Bot-Avatar
hat. Die hat es in den letzten Tagen
ein bisschen verkackt. Auch
Video-Ankündigungen kamen nicht. Stream-Ankündigungen
kamen teilweise zu spät.
Wettke.
Immerhin, das funktioniert. Aber Video hat auch nicht
funktioniert gestern. Ja, also
ich kann es nochmal sagen. Wenn ihr irgendwelche interessanten Videos
habt, die wir heute gucken sollen, dann schickt mal her.
Der YouTube-Algorithmus, ich zeige euch das mal.
Der YouTube-Algorithmus versagt komplett
heute bei mir.
Ich meine, was ich
ist das? So, ich refreshe jetzt
mal. Was ist das?
Peter Altmaier lässt sich nicht den
Kuchen verboten. Warum kriege ich das empfohlen?
Gut, klar, das ist irgendein
Meme, Verarschung und sonst was.
She's a truck. Who cares?
Alter, was sind
das für Video-Empfehlungen?
Was sind das für Video-Empfehlungen? Davon interessiert mich überhaupt
nichts. Was ist das hier?
Das ist so fail. Was macht
der Algorithmus? Guckt euch das mal an.
Da ist nur Crap dabei.
Das ist, ich sag doch, komplett
geimpft. Bist du schon geimpft? Ja, einmal.
Einmal bin ich geimpft.
Das ist komplett,
komplett,
Warum heißt das eigentlich Kaufmann
WMX? Warum heißt das nicht
Kauf
Kaufbinnen
oder so? Oder Kauffrauen
und Kaufmänner und Kaufichse
oder irgendwie sowas. Kaufix
zum Beispiel, ja?
Es hat überhaupt keine Logik zu schreiben
Kaufmann mit NN und dann
WMX. Wie soll das funktionieren?
Man könnte es vielleicht Kaufmann
nennen, so mit einem N.
Ergibt alles wenig Sinn, gebe ich zu.
Gehaltsgespräch,
kompletter Beispiel.
Das gucken wir uns nicht an. Das ist bestimmt
total
cringe dieser Kram.
So schön gestellt.
Der Kaufmann, genau.
Kaufmensch, Kaufperson.
Guck mal, ich krieg Video von mir empfohlen.
Muss man immer aufmachen. Immer wenn Videos
von mir empfohlen werden, muss man die aufmachen. Das gibt
Algorithmus-Boost.
Dann erst mal
laufen lassen. Easy.
Auch wenn ich mir dieses Video jetzt tatsächlich
angucken würde, ich darf diese Videos
nicht angucken, weil der Algorithmus dann auch noch
denkt, ich will das gucken. Ich will
diesen ganzen Kram nicht empfohlen bekommen.
Präsentation Fachinformatiker
Systemirger. Ich hab schon zwei
Videoempfehlungen dazu bekommen. Das reicht.
Wie ist denn jetzt, jetzt mal doofe Frage.
Vielleicht weiß das einer von euch. Wie ist
dann jetzt eigentlich
Schau Discord-Vorschläge
Pfeifert, BGP stellt. Genau, BGP.
Stellt's muss ich echt nicht machen.
Wie ist denn jetzt eigentlich die korrekte
Art und Weise, sowas zu
schreiben? Weil, ich lese
ja relativ viel
im IT-News-Seiten und da
setzt sich das auch immer mehr durch,
dass man nicht schreibt, Kaufmänner
und Kauffrauen, sondern dass man irgendwie so die
so diese, wie nennt man das
eigentlich, diese
neu erdachte allgemeingültige
Schreibweise macht, so nach dem
Motto InformatikerInnen. Aber
was ich nicht verstehe ist, wie schreibt man das jetzt eigentlich?
Mit nem Sternchen, mit nem
Unterstrich, mit nem Doppelpunkt,
mit nem großen I
oder mit nem kleinen I. Ich hab's sogar
schon mit Leerzeichen gesehen.
Wie ist jetzt da eigentlich
richtig? Also wie würde
man Informatiker, außerdem
ist das in der Aussprache auch übelst
schwierig.
Du musst anhand der Pause erkennen
irgendwie,
ob du jetzt nur
Frauen meinst oder beide. Also
ich finde das äußerst
hakelig, ja.
Das C++
das ist gut.
Ja, in C++ wäre das
tatsächlich so. Also ich
komm da nicht so ganz klar drauf
irgendwie, was denn da jetzt
und was denn da jetzt nicht.
Wichtig ist doch, dass man weiß, wer gemeint ist.
Was beneiden Japaner an
Deutsch? Das juckt mich überhaupt nicht.
Was ich an Japanern beneide, das kann ich
euch sagen. Dass da alles, zumindest
so wie das immer in Videos aussieht, alles ultra
sauber ist.
Ich glaube, sowas wie Frankfurt Hauptbahnhof gibt's in Japan
nicht. Oder Berlin Hauptbahnhof.
Sowas
gibt's in Japan glaube ich nicht.
Wir überraschen ihn mit krassem
Gaming-Setup.
Was ist mit dem Algorithmus los
heute, Alter? Da ist ja, da ist nichts
da ist nichts
dabei. Wenn ich schon
jetzt hauptsächlich meine eigenen Videos empfohlen
kriege, da stimmt doch irgendwas nicht.
Okay, Gehalt eines Informatikers.
Wollen wir wetten, Leute?
Wollen wir wetten, wenn ich das Video auf
mache, sitzt da nicht
die Rothaarige da aus dem Thumbnail
vorm Rechner? Wollen wir wetten?
Bäm.
Ich wusste es.
Das war so klar.
Aber ich würde auch so ein Thumbnail machen, da klickt
man einfach drauf.
She made it.
Naja, logisch.
Es gibt nichts. Der Algorithmus ist einfach
unfähig heute.
Schießt es mal an.
Schnelltests. Trefferquote
unter 50%. Wisst ihr, was auch
unter 50%?
Die Likes bei dem Video.
Garantiert.
Okay.
Ich hab mich vertan.
Ich hab mich vertan. Fast.
Fast.
Was, das Video von der IHK?
Ah, das haben wir schon mal
geguckt. Das haben wir schon mal
geguckt. Das war, glaube ich, gar nicht
so schlecht, das Video.
Auch wenn es ein bisschen
an der Realität vorbei war. Aber die möchten, dass
ich das nochmal gucke. Wir haben das vor zwei Jahren
schon mal geguckt. Guck mal.
Jetzt kriege ich...
Jetzt kriege ich mein Klo-Video empfohlen
und daneben ein Tag
Fachinformatiker.
Das sind vielleicht... Das ist... Das will ich
aber doch jetzt nicht gucken.
Es gibt nichts. Es ist wirklich der Wahnsinn.
Hey, ihr alten Zerstörer. Das haben wir
schon geguckt letzte Woche.
Jetzt kriegen wir einen Plants vs. Zombies
ähm...
Tutorial
in 2021.
Leute, was ist...
Also der YouTube-Algorithmus heute ist
komplett los. Wir machen jetzt mal was.
Wir gucken mal, wie so der 0815
Besucher in Deutschland
YouTube sieht.
Ach, du Scheiße.
Das ist ja... Das ist ja noch schlimmer.
Ich habe gedacht, das hier wird... Das ist ja noch schlimmer.
Ach, du Scheiße.
Der Dark-Mode. Der 0815-Noob hat auch kein Dark-Mode an.
Ach, du Scheiße. Was kriege ich denn hier für einen Müll?
Das habe ich geguckt vor einer Woche oder so.
Zerstörte Dörfer an der...
Ja.
Äh, was haben sie denn da zu...
Das ist scheiße, ja, aber...
Das muss ich mir nicht noch zusätzlich nochmal angucken.
Es wird davon nicht besser.
Es ist, also...
Okay, okay.
Dieses Video, dieses Video hat hauptsächlich erstmal so viele Klicks,
weil dort auf dem Samtnet eine steht, die so gut wie nichts anhat.
Die Leute denken sich so nach dem Motto,
hm, dieses Bild muss ich mir mal in groß angucken.
Und machen dann das Video auf.
Und dann kommt das noch nicht mal in den Video.
Dann fährt da so ein komisches Schiff.
Also, mal ganz im Ernst.
YouTube hier, Startseite, das ist ja noch schlimmer als das, was ich empfohlen krieg.
Das ist nix für mich, Alter.
Wahnsinn.
Es ist heute, also der Algorithmus ist broken, das Wochenende.
Lass Dokus von der Flut schauen.
Nee, das ist ein äußerst deprimierendes Thema.
Das muss ich mir nicht angucken.
Außer, wird's davon nicht besser, wenn wir uns das angucken.
Also, ihr seht, es gibt nur Müll auf YouTube gerade.
Außer natürlich das da.
Das ist das Gute, das sollt ihr euch alle angucken.
Ihr wisst ja, eigene Videos immer öffnen.
Das ist gut für den Algorithmus.
Perfekt.
Impfpflicht ohne Impfung keine Freiheit.
Also, dazu kann ich nur sagen, ich lass mich impfen in zwei Wochen.
Aber, sollte wirklich jemand auf die Idee kommen und zu sagen,
ich muss mich impfen lassen, sonst gibt's Strafe,
dann bin ich der Erste, der das absagt.
Das seh ich nicht ein.
Ich mach das freiwillig, weil ich's für sinnvoll halt,
aber ich hasse es, bevormundet zu werden.
Es gibt kaum was, was ich mehr hasse,
als wenn mir irgendjemand sagen soll, was ich machen soll.
Ähm, selbst wenn ich, selbst wenn ich, äh, der gleichen Ansicht bin.
Also, wenn irgendjemand sagt, du musst das machen, sonst musst du Strafe bezahlen,
dann sag ich, leck mich, mach ich nicht.
Aber so wird's wahrscheinlich, so weit wird's wahrscheinlich nicht kommen.
So schlimm war die Gaming Night der jungen Union.
Oh, das ist Painz Champ.
Das ist Painz Champ. Das ist Painz Champ.
Das ist richtig.
Da kann dann, da kann dann Philipp Amthor wieder sagen,
hallo ihr alten Zerstörer, so was hier, genau, ihr alten Zerstörer.
Stimmt es, dass man mit der Impfung nur sich selbst schützt?
Ich hab ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung.
Aber kann ja, kann ja an sich nicht stimmen.
Selbst wenn du's bekommst, also selbst wenn du noch ansteckend wärst,
bist du's wahrscheinlich nicht so lang und nicht so sehr.
Aber ich hab keine Ahnung.
Aber es reicht schon, wenn ich mich selbst schütze.
Das reicht mir ehrlich gesagt schon.
Das ist schon genug für mich.
Das ist okay.
So.
Es ist, was Pegasus spielen wird und wie wir uns schützen.
Auf dem neuen iPhone geht der Kram gar nicht mehr.
Oder?
Vor allem Apple untersucht.
Aha.
Okay.
Praktisches Beispiel für Gutrechte.
Oh, das ist Big Brain Time.
Das ist Big Brain Time.
Ist schon.
Ach, guck mal.
Das ist so schnell.
Du kannst es eigentlich einfach mit choosing
Analog f consiglio
solis.
ein gescheites Video gucken, nicht irgendwelche
Meme-Videos. Das geht nur, wenn man
eingeloggt ist, was ich übrigens total hängen geblieben finde.
Das würde auch genauso gut funktionieren,
wenn ich nicht eingeloggt bin.
Die machen ja eh ein Profil von meinem User.
Auch wenn ich nicht eingeloggt bin.
Mach doch einen Stream-Account.
Ja, kann ich machen,
aber warum? Normalerweise klappt's ja auch so.
Ah, naja.
So, dann, dann. Da müssen wir jetzt erstmal zum
Entspannen eine Runde...
Wir lassen uns jetzt mal jibben von Level Cap.
Wo ist das hier?
Ah, okay.
Meine Videos mach ich mal dicht.
Äh...
Wo ist der Level Cap, G-Bait?
Anderes Fenster.
Du musst anklicken, 5 Sekunden gucken, dann zumachen. Aha.
Das ist aber normal, dass innerhalb
der ersten 5 Sekunden,
keine Ahnung, 30%, 40% der Leute abschalten.
Okay, sag mal. Ich glaub, bei mir
schalten innerhalb der ersten...
Also bei mir sind nach den ersten irgendwie
30 Sekunden im Durchschnitt, glaube ich,
noch irgendwie 75% der Zuschauer
dabei. Also das ist normal.
Dass irgendwie 25...
Dass die 25-30% erstmal instant quitten.
Freedom Phone.
Okay.
Wir lassen uns jetzt von Level Cap jibben.
Da ist bestimmt nichts Interessantes dabei.
Aber da jibbetet uns immer der Kerl.
Also, jibbeten.
Jawohl.
Ich mag die Aussprache
von Amis von Multiplayer.
Die sagen ja Multiplayer.
Und ja, unser Team hat ein Problem.
Das ist einfach sehr, sehr...
...seriös.
...seriös Problem.
Und viel mehr.
Viel mehr Entwickler aus Dyson Ripple Effect
haben Interviews gemacht
über Battlefield 2042 diese Woche.
Kennst du schon die neue Avira-Werbung?
Angeblich schützt Avira...
Nee, kenn ich nicht.
Haben die ein Video? Schick mal das.
Gucken wir uns her und ketten ne Runde.
...viel Details über vieles, was wir schon wussteten.
Aber sie haben auch ein paar Themen aufgewertet,
die wir noch wussten.
Battlefield 2042 wird keine
rankenden oder eSports-Modelle anbieten.
Ich dachte, Hazard Zone sollte genau sowas werden.
Mal gucken.
Mal gucken, mal gucken.
Ja gut, Incursion, Incursion, erinnert sich noch einer an Incursion, Alter?
Incursion war ja komplett, komplett dead.
Das ist ja noch nicht mal released worden.
Incursions wurde angekündigt und dann kam ne Beta raus, es hat keine Sau interessiert
und dann wurde es nie fertig gemacht.
Die hatten ja damals noch so ein Reveal-Video, wo irgendwelche angeblichen E-Sport-Pros gesessen haben
und haben das gespielt und keiner davon war ein E-Sport-Pro.
Ich glaube, der Einzige, den ich davon gekannt habe, das war aber auch kein E-Sport-Pro,
das kennt noch einer, Whiteboy7street, der hat früher Call of Duty-Videos gemacht,
der war in diesem Video noch dabei, wo ich mir gedacht habe, was zum Geier macht der Typ da?
Und es hat keinen interessiert.
Tschüss.
Incursion ist Path of Exile-League, ja, stimmt.
Weil dabei könnte man das, dabei könnte man das machen.
Ich hab das schon oft gesagt, ich bin der Ansicht, Squad Rush, vielleicht nicht unbedingt zu viert,
vielleicht könnte man das irgendwie zu nem 6 vs. 6 erweitern oder sowas.
Viert ist vielleicht ein bisschen wenig, 5 vs. 5, 6 vs. 6.
Squad Rush auf gescheiten Maps, finde ich, ist der battlefieldigste E-Sport-Modus, den man machen könnte.
Hier die Werbung.
Oh ne, das ist bestimmt Grinch-Werbung.
Wollen wir gleich gucken.
Ach, das geht ja nur 17 Sekunden, das ist ja nix.
Ich dachte, da kommt jetzt irgendwas Painschampiges.
Aha.
Okay, man nimmt also ein Bild, was zwar von dem Wort her was mit dem Thema zu tun hat,
aber von dem Ereignis her nichts mit dem Thema zu tun hat.
Ne, publish ich nicht auf GitHub.
Außerdem, die Katz will den Fisch gar nicht fangen.
Wenn die den Fisch hätte fangen wollen, das würde anders aussehen.
Okay, das ist ja kaum was.
Kaum was zu sagen zu der Werbung.
Awesome!
Ja, alles klar.
Huge.
Ja, kann man nichts zu sagen.
Aber warum Protected Avira vor Phishing-Angriffen?
Guck das beispielsweise, wenn du persönliche Informationen überträgst, in irgendein Feld eintippst oder sowas.
Also ich kann mir schon vorstellen, dass eine, nennen wir es mal so, irgendwie Antivirus,
das ist ja nicht wirklich reine Antivirus-Software, sowas wie Avira, dass das potenziell schon was dagegen machen kann.
Ja.
Das habe ich vergessen reinzumachen.
Wuppetke.
Das habe ich hier nur gespeichert.
Stimmt, stimmt.
Muss ich noch reinmachen.
Immer dieses gleiche Gelaber.
Also, ich dachte eigentlich, Hazard Zone wird so eine Art Competitive-Modus.
Die sagen ja, Squadplay, High Stakes, blablabla.
Und wenn Hazard Zone da halt standardmäßig nicht drin ist, okay, dann kommt es später.
Aber ich würde es sehr wundern, wenn die das nicht machen.
Ich meine, die hätten, die würden, guck mal, die würden noch ganz schön viel Potenzial,
vor allem für ein Spiel, was die über Jahre supporten wollen.
Wahrscheinlich.
Mal gucken.
Und nicht, dass sie es wieder in Battlefield 5 machen.
Für ein Spiel, was die Jahre supporten wollen wahrscheinlich.
Wäre es doch bescheuert, wenn die jetzt schon Battle Royale Links liegen lassen und wenigstens,
nicht mal den Versuch unternehmen würden, das ein bisschen Competitive spielbar zu machen.
Da würden sie auch viel Links liegen lassen.
Das glaube ich nicht.
Und ich glaube ja übrigens immer noch nicht dran, dass sie nicht in irgendeiner Art und Weise auf Battlefield Battle Royale noch schielen.
Eine Feature, die DICE implementieren, sind persistenzfreie Bands auf customen Servern.
Battlefield 5s Community-Modus.
Das System lässt Server-Admins Bands verhindern, aber die Bands haben nur so lange gedauert, bis der Server aktiv war.
Ja gut, das ist ja beknackt.
Das ist ja beknackt, ne?
Das ist das Problem, wenn du keine Plugins mehr bei Servern installieren kannst.
Bei Battlefield 4, da konntest du, bei Battlefield 1-Servern weiß ich es nicht,
aber bei Battlefield 4-Servern, da konntest du beispielsweise noch Server-Plugins installieren.
Da hattest du ja auch noch eine richtige Server-Konsole und alles.
Und da konntest du auch übergreifende Bands implementieren.
Das ist halt das Problem, wenn man das alles so restriktiv macht.
Das ist halt für den Arsch.
Auf der anderen Seite muss man sagen, viele Leute wurden ja auch gerade, also richtig gute Leute,
wurden ja auch in Battlefield 4 gebannt.
Die haben dann 5 Accounts gebraucht, weil die einfach gut gespielt haben.
Und irgendein Server-Typ sich gedacht hat, ne, ne, ne, das kann nicht sein.
... known cheaters out of matches.
Portals bans were persistent.
If you ban a player from one portal server, they'll be banned from every new server that you create.
And hopefully this will allow players to police hackers on their own a bit more.
Extra.
... since the hackers stole them.
... a full source code from the Frostbite engine from EA.
The hackers say that they have an exploit that works on most Frostbite titles.
There's a big concern that cheaters may descend on Battlefield 2042 like never before.
Also, jetzt mal ernsthaft.
Ob die jetzt Frostbite-Code geklaut haben oder nicht, ist doch vollkommen unerheblich.
Es gibt jetzt schon massig Hacks für alle Battlefields, also Hacks ist vielleicht das Wort, Cheats.
Massig Cheats für alle Battlefields.
Und es ist doch, warum sollte es einen Frostbite-Source-Code-Leak, wie auch immer, brauchen, dass jemand für Battlefield 2042 Cheats entwickelt?
Das kannst du doch vergessen.
Das wird auch so passieren.
Gut, vielleicht macht es das jetzt in irgendeiner Art und Weise einfacher, aber das bezweifle ich sogar, dass es einen nennenswerten Unterschied macht.
Es wird, es wird, also ich sag, ich sag, ich sag euch jetzt.
Wie es ist, die Beta von diesem Game ist spielbar und es gibt ab dem, wenn nicht ab dem ersten Tag, dann gibt es ab dem zweiten Tag Cheats, die funktionieren.
Die Frage ist nicht, ob es Cheats geben wird, die Frage ist, wie geht EA gegen Cheats vor?
Cheats wirst du nicht verhindern können, gerade auf dem PC, besonders schwer.
Wie geht EA dagegen vor?
Was hat EA für Möglichkeiten, da was zu erkennen und was hat EA auch für Möglichkeiten quasi automatisieren?
Also über irgendwelche statistischen Auswertungen, meinetwegen, wenn wir 2021 sind, dass man dann auch sagt, ey, bam, per Machine Learning, was auch immer, da Statistiken zu untersuchen, ob das Cheating-Potenzial hat.
Das ist die Frage, was sie dagegen machen.
Das kostet richtig Geld.
Wenn die Machine Learning AI-Cheats kommen, dann ist es eh vorbei.
Das glaube ich nicht.
Ich glaube, das gibt ein neues Wettrennen zwischen Cheat-Detection und Cheats.
Also es gibt ja jetzt schon genug Cheats, die nicht wirklich erkennbar sind.
Da hatten wir es ja vor, da wollte ich übrigens auch mal ein Video zu machen, muss ich mal aufschreiben.
Also, da hatten wir ja vor einer Weile, habe ich auch mal dazu geäußert, also es gibt ja jetzt schon einen Haufen Cheats, die praktisch nicht erkennbar sind.
Das ist vielleicht auch nicht so verbreitet.
Da gibt es mehrere Varianten.
Es gibt die komplett unabhängige Variante.
Also du hast ein Capture-Device dran und du hast ein Input-Device.
Also der Rechner hat kein, also es wird nicht direkt auf den Arbeitsspeicher irgendwie zugegriffen vom Spiel.
Also du merkst das nicht.
Das einzige, was die Cheats machen ist, Output abgreifen und Input liefern.
Gibt es bei Valorant beispielsweise schon was.
Da kannst du in Valorant, da schleifst du das durch eine Capture-Karte durch, analysierst die Bilder und dann hast du quasi Input an der Maus, der für dich triggert und sowas.
Es ist eigentlich auf dem Rechner selbst undetectable.
Weil du nichts auf dem Rechner drauf hast.
So, dann hast du die nächste Variante, die eigentlich auch nicht wirklich zu detecten ist, die aber sogar noch besser funktioniert, weil du keine AI trainieren musst.
Es gibt die Variante, dass du Hardware einbaust in den Rechner, die sich tarnt als, sagen wir mal, Netzwerkkarte oder irgendwas.
Also irgendwas, was die unmöglich bannen können, weil jeder eine Netzwerkkarte hat.
Und diese Hardware greift über einen Windows-Treiber auf den Arbeitsspeicher zu.
Also als PCI-Express-Gerät auf den Arbeitsspeicher.
Vom Spiel.
Das ist auch nicht wirklich detectbar.
Und dann macht es Dinge damit auf einem externen Microcontroller und schickt beispielsweise auch Inputs an die Maus und die Tastatur.
Also das sind beide Sachen, die sind so gut wie nicht detectbar.
Aber, und selbst wenn wir mal beide Sachen nehmen, aber natürlich ist es in gewisser Weise schon zu erkennen.
Allerdings nicht kleinseitig.
Sondern...
Da muss man sich halt überlegen, okay, wie erkenne ich bestimmte Muster in den Statistiken, die man aufteilt.
Games müssen sau viele Statistiken sammeln, ja.
Da reicht es nicht nur so nach dem Motto, wie viel Damage pro Sekunde mache ich.
Die müssen sammeln, Damage pro Sekunde, wie genau ist quasi mein Aiming, wie oft über-Aime ich, wie schnell erkenne ich, zum Beispiel, das ist auch so eine Sache,
wie schnell erkenne ich von, da ist ein Gegner zu.
Der ersten Reaktion, das ist ja auch sowas, das ist AI-technisch Instant, je nachdem, wenn du keine Delays einbaust, und das werden sie dann auch machen, so nach dem Motto, ich erkenne Gegner, reagiere Instant, aber versuche dann, mein Aim ein bisschen zu verschleiern.
Also, was ich damit sagen will, ist, ich glaube, das wird einfach ein komplett neues Wettrüsten auslösen zwischen AI-Cheats und AI-Anti-Cheat.
Und das ist nicht abzusehen, wer das Ganze gewinnt.
Wahrscheinlich wird das gar keiner gewinnen.
Das wird so weitergehen, wie die letzten Jahre, dass es, tja, je nachdem, was für einen Hersteller man erwischt, mal mehr, mal weniger gut funktioniert.
Naja gut, das kannst du machen, aber du kannst es ja einfach ändern.
Also, wenn du eine Hardware hast, wo du dann auch noch flashen kannst, als welche Sache, die sich meldet, und du wirst im Leben nicht eine Hardware sperren können, die eine 0815-Netzwerkkarte ist.
Wie willst du das machen?
Zumal, die immer eine andere MAC hat.
Die immer eine leicht andere ID hat.
Da wirst du nichts dagegen machen.
Das sage ich ja.
Die Sachen sind theoretisch zwar feststellbar, aber sauschwer.
Cheats, die nur Output ausgreifen und Input liefern, sind überhaupt nicht feststellbar.
Also, es ist echt schwierig mittlerweile.
Deswegen müssen die auch Anti-Cheat-Technik aufrüsten.
So, machen wir mal weiter.
Wir haben es jetzt geschafft, 20 Minuten über 1,55 Video zu reden.
Excellent.
Das Leak.
Portals persistent Bans may help players get by.
The Halo Infinite Multiplayer Technical Preview got off to a rough start.
Invited players were unable to redeem their access codes for the test.
Servers went down almost instantly.
Matchmaking has known bugs, preventing players from consistently joining matches.
And there's also some big performance issues and gameplay bugs.
But despite all of that, it's actually proving to be very popular with those who are playing it.
Most say 343 have crafted a satisfying multiplayer that stays true to Halo's legacy titles.
Es wird mal wieder Zeit für einen ordentlichen Halo-Multiplayer, den die Leute auch länger als zwei Monate spielen.
Das letzte war Halo 3.
Halo 3.
Halo 3 MLG Playlist.
Chat, Chat.
Klärt mich auf.
Welche, welche Space Frog Sache?
Äh, hä?
Chat, ihr müsst mir das erklären.
Five hat time.
Bungie soll mal wieder Halo machen, das wirst du nicht mehr erleben.
The ending of the story and more.
Of course, I'm not going to be sharing any of the spoilers here, but just be aware that people are sharing them on social media, so just watch out.
If you're looking for a more in-depth look at the...
multiplayer preview, be sure to check out our video on it.
The state of California filed a lawsuit against Activision Blizzard that makes some very serious allegations.
Investors found evidence of rampant sexual harassment.
Die junge Union hat einen Gaming-Stream gemacht mit Amthor und irgendwie hat da mitgelockt, was im Chat alles gelöscht wurde.
Was heißt irgendwer? Hast du das mitgelockt?
Ich mein, irgendwie muss ja jetzt der Chat auf dich kommen, so nach dem Motto, irgendwas musst du ja damit zu tun haben.
Hacker-Mans im Chat wieder hier.
...harassment, abuse, sexism and more during their two-year investigation.
Vielleicht war ich da involviert, ja.
A female employee took her own life after being assaulted during a company getaway.
Activision Blizzard dismissed the allegations in their initial statement, calling the lawsuit irresponsible behavior from unacceptable state bureaucrats that are driving many of the state's businesses out of California.
In response, employees staged a walkout to this...
...statement.
CEO Bobby Kotick issued a company-wide open letter calling the company's initial response to a death.
Ja, das kennen wir schon.
...despite his letter.
Das kennen wir schon und die Antworten von den Activision Blizzard-Management-Leuten war halt überall komplett lächerlich.
...they were making several promises to improve the company and take allegations seriously.
Am besten fand ich die Antwort von der, war das die Inklusions-Antidiskriminierungsbeauftragte oder so?
Ich weiß nicht, welche Position das ist.
Die geschrieben hat, das ist bei Activision Blizzard jetzt...
...Anti-Antisexismus, Antirassismus, Antidiskriminierungs-, Antimobbingkurse gibt und jetzt ist alles gut, ja.
Weil, ich stelle mir das so vor, ja, du hast irgendjemand, der sich wahnsinnig darüber freut, andere Leute abzufacken.
So, dem macht das richtig Spaß.
Der wird dann in so einen Antimobbingkurs geschickt und die sagen ihm dann, das ist aber nicht okay.
Und dann sagt er, ach, da wäre ich nie drauf gekommen.
Jetzt gut, dass sie mir das mal sagen.
Ich hätte nie damit gerechnet, dass das andere Leute abfackt.
Das heißt, ich werde es jetzt weiterhin machen, aber nicht mehr so offensichtlich.
Das ist dann die Reaktion der Leute drauf.
Die machen es dann einfach weniger offensichtlich, ja.
Genau, für den ist es eine Schulung, wie er noch mehr Leute abfacken kann oder Geheime abfacken kann.
Wisst ihr, mir ist es lieber, es macht einer öffentlich, so nach dem Motto, keine Ahnung, man sitzt in einem Meeting...
...und sagt einer...
Max, dein Vorschlag ist scheiße, wie immer.
So, das ist mir lieber, als wenn irgendwie einer so ultra passiv-aggressiv ist.
Keine Ahnung, da fällt mir jetzt kein gutes Beispiel dazu ein.
Aber wisst ihr, wenn man das dann versteckter macht, so nach dem Motto, ihr werdet mir doch sicher recht geben...
...niemand würde...
...solch einen Vorschlag ernst irgendwie...
Wisst ihr, wie ich meine, dass man das dann nicht so offensichtlich macht.
Also mir ist es wirklich lieber, jemand macht das direkt.
Weil dann kannst du auch dementsprechend darauf antworten.
Dann kannst du sagen, ja, Alter, fick dich.
So übertrieben gesagt, ja.
Anstatt immer so durch die Blume, so um die Ecke.
Weil dann, wenn du jemanden anscheißt dafür...
...und es bekommen Leute mit, die das andere nicht konstant mitbekommen...
...dann denken die, du bist der Böse, weil du den jetzt angeschissen hast.
Versteht man, was ich meine?
Also das heißt, mit solchen Anti-Mobbing-Kursen bringst du den Leuten dann wahrscheinlich nur auf den Trichter...
...dass die jetzt das Ganze ein bisschen hinterhältiger machen müssen.
So, weiter.
Ja, macht's auch.
Matters worse, Activision Blizzard hired a union-busting law firm, WilmerHale, to review their HR policies.
Many view this as the company preemptively thwarting attempts to unionize or organize by employees.
Outsiders from across the gaming industry have openly encouraged Activision Blizzard employees to organize a union.
WilmerHale most recently prevented Amazon's warehouse workers from unionizing.
Ja, also, mir fällt übrigens ein gutes Beispiel eingefallen, was so passiv-aggressiv...
...wäre, zum Beispiel, ja.
Also, so direkt in your face wäre so nach dem Motto, Max, dein Vorschlag ist scheiße wie immer.
So, das ist das, wenn das jemand auf einem Meeting sagt, kannst du wenigstens dementsprechend drauf reagieren.
Ja, aber wenn zum Beispiel jemand sagt, wir sollten ein öffentliches...
...also du machst einen Vorschlag, ja, und irgendjemand sagt dann, wir sollten ein öffentliches Board für schlechte Ideen einrichten.
Sowas in der Richtung, ja.
Das ist nicht so direkt.
Max, du bist scheiße.
Das ist so, hat eigentlich gar nichts so direkt damit zu tun, aber es ist klar, auf was sich es bezieht, ja.
Sowas.
Und die Leute lernen es dann eher mit der Zeit, dass sie das noch hinterhältiger machen müssen, was auch nicht gut ist.
Also, wenn schon, sollen sie es eher direkt machen.
Da kannst du nämlich dementsprechend oft reagieren.
Sony hat eine Beta-Update für die PlayStation 5 eröffnet, die endlich ihre interne Storage-Expansion-Slotte aktiviert.
Die Anwender, die die Update installiert haben, können...
Ja, nee, nee, nee.
Deine Ideen sind immer resitierbar.
Denn Sleeper ist ja auch direkt.
Das bezieht sich ja direkt auf mich.
Es gibt aber Leute, die haben das perfektioniert.
Die sagen dann nicht mehr so nach dem Motto, deine Idee ist scheiße.
Die drücken das so um die Ecke aus.
So nach dem Motto, wir sollten auch mal einen Review-Prozess etablieren, der Ideen von solchen Meetings unter die Lupe nimmt.
So nach dem Motto.
Du bist jetzt, wo du eigentlich genau weißt, was Sache ist, aber er meint im Prinzip, deine Idee ist scheiße und möchte das auch so verpacken.
Aber es nicht direkt sagen.
Ja.
Genau, genau.
Das genau.
Hat noch...
Genau, das ist auch so was so nach dem Motto, gibt's hier auch noch gute Ideen oder sowas.
Ja, das ist genau solche Dinge.
Aber es gibt Leute, die haben das drauf, die können quasi schon nicht mehr anders reden als so.
Die müssen jedes Kommentar irgendwie so spicken, als sind sie die Schlauesten und alles andere ist doof.
Und das ist wirklich ätzend.
Toxic, genau.
Ja, gut.
Hat es überhaupt irgendjemand gekauft, die neue Xbox?
Ja, das, genau sowas wäre auch mal.
Okay, ich hab mir jetzt den Vorschlag notiert.
Und dann irgendwie noch sowas dabei zu sagen.
Das müssen wir aber dann nochmal im Detail genau erklären.
Ich seh da noch einige, einige Probleme oder irgendwie sowas.
Man kann das ganz schwer sagen.
Es kommt von Situation zu Situation, zu Person zu Person an.
Weil, wisst ihr, so zu allen anderen Vorschlägen sagen so, ah, das ist, das ist cool, super guter Vorschlag.
Und bei deinem, wenn ihr euch nicht abkönnt, dann immer sowas einbauen.
Ja.
Wie heißen die jetzt eigentlich richtig?
Xbox Series X und Xbox Series S, ne?
...Storage for the PlayStation 5 requires popping off a side panel and unscrewing the drive bay compartment.
The benefit of Sony's solution is that you can use any compatible SSD.
Microsoft's drives are proprietary and will probably stay at a more fixed price over time with limited options in terms of capacity.
DayZ creator Dean Hall's new survival game Icarus has been delayed to November.
Pre-order players will get access to the beta weekends starting in August.
Sieht ja auch Residenz lieber aus.
The devs released a roadmap for these beta weekends that explains their content and availability.
Ach, das ist das, wo die dann in so einem Raumanzug landen.
Und survive, surviven müssen, ne?
Haben wir irgendwo mal einen Trailer gesehen.
Hat mich jetzt auch nicht persönlich sonderlich gejuckt.
Icarus was originally launching on August 11th, so it's not a massive delay.
Ja, genau das Ding, das da meine ich ja.
Reviews of the game do look promising.
Who cares?
Wisst ihr, wisst ihr, als hätten wir jetzt ein neues, weiteres Survival-Crafting-Game gebraucht.
Das ist wie vor ein paar Jahren, wo alle, alle paar Wochen ein neues Zombie-Game rausgekommen ist, ja?
Gibt es wirklich noch Leute, die sagen, oh ja, unbedingt.
Survival-Game mit Crafting-Elementen, das ist es jetzt.
Da brauchen wir noch mehr von.
Am besten noch mit Battle Royale.
Ist eigentlich, ist eigentlich Warts irgendwann mal fertig geworden?
Was ja nicht mal Warts heißt, was ja jetzt Infestation, Survivor Stories oder so heißt.
Ist das, ist das jemals fertig geworden?
Oder, oder was ist, was ist mit dem Klassiker Dates?
Ist Dates irgendwann mal fertig geworden?
Irgendwann mal fertig geworden?
Das hat eh jeder vergessen.
...before time runs out.
Surviving requires a mix of gathering resources, base building and fighting off the wildlife.
Destiny 2's crossplay system...
Würdest du das Riot Games MMO mal testen?
Auf jeden Fall.
Würde ich auf jeden Fall ausprobieren, wenn es das gibt.
Ich hatte zwar mit LOL nix am Hut, aber ich traue Riot Games auf jeden Fall zu, ein ordentliches MMO zu machen.
Mehr als ab und zu.
Die haben aber auch den riesen Vorteil.
Wisst ihr was?
Dass...
Das...
Also ich...
Meine persönliche, meine persönliche Meinung.
Ich denke, dass League of Legends, also wenn, wenn man so weit geht und sagt, dass irgendjemand mal wieder was in, in, in, ja, in Größe, in Größe wie WoW produzieren könnte.
Ich denke, dass die einzige Firma, die das machen könnte, aktuell tatsächlich Riot ist, weil der Hype in, in World of Warcraft damals war ja durch mehrere Sachen ausgelöst.
Erstens, es war eines der ersten so richtigen Mainstream-tauglichen MMOs.
Auch ein richtig gutes MMO.
Und die Leute waren halt riesige Warcraft-Fanboys vorher schon.
Und so ist das bei LOL auch.
LOL hat eine riesen Fanbase.
LOL hat bis jetzt nie so wirklich großartig was mit Story gemacht.
Die haben natürlich...
Es gibt ja diese...
Es ist ja...
Die LOL...
Die LOL-Story ist ja irgendwie so.
Du bist ein Summoner.
Also du bist quasi irgend so ein Gedankensteuer-Dude.
Und dann hast du, dann hast du da dein...
Deine...
bin ich so wahnsinnig drin, was League of Legends
angeht. Aber die haben jetzt ja auch eine World Map
und Erklärungen zu verschiedenen Orten
und sonst was. Also die haben da richtig
was die Sammler sind, gestrichen. Okay,
kann auch sein. Keine Ahnung.
Zumindest, die sind da richtig
gut dabei. Und die haben einen Vorteil,
den WoW damals auch hatte.
Das ist, die haben schon eine riesen Fanbase,
bevor das Game rauskommt.
Und ich könnte mir echt vorstellen, dass das,
wenn das ein gutes Game wird,
dass das richtig reinhaut.
Und ich meine, die haben es mit Valorant
ja auch geschafft, ein Game rauszuhauen, was komplett
anders ist als LoL.
Aber sich doch ganz gut spielt. Wobei
ich sagen muss, Valorant,
also ich hab's, ich gucke
ab und zu mal ein bisschen Valorant. Ich hab
das nie selbst gespielt. Ich finde aber
die Streams teilweise ganz, ganz unterhaltsam.
Was mir persönlich rein als Zuschauer
in Valorant so ein bisschen
negativ auffällt, ist die Maps.
Oder sind die Maps. Die Maps
sehen etwas, wie soll ich
sagen, also mir geht's jetzt nicht um die
Spielbarkeit oder so. Da kann ich nichts dazu sagen.
Die Maps sehen ein bisschen
aus, als wären die,
sagen wir mal, als wären die Level-Designer jetzt nicht
die allergrößten
groß. Ja.
Also ich rede jetzt nicht von der Spielbarkeit,
sondern
wie die Maps gemacht sind.
Die wirken auf mich
vom Anschauen teilweise eben ein bisschen
ich will nicht sagen amateurhaft,
das ist falsch. Ich könnte es garantiert nicht
besser.
Genau, man fragt sich, was die Level-Designer beruflich machen.
Aber gar nicht so sehr von der Spielbarkeit.
Da kann ich nichts zu sagen.
Die Maps sehen an sich einfach nicht gut
durchdacht aus.
Wenn ich dann zum Beispiel sehe,
Alter,
wie da manche Maps zusammenhängen.
Das mag ja vom Layout okay sein
für die Spielbarkeit, aber es ergibt
einfach in sich geschlossen von so
einem, von so einer, so eine Map erzählt
ja auch immer eine gewisse Story. Ja, die
eine Map, nennen wir jetzt mal eine Overwatch-Map,
ja, nehmen wir jetzt mal Kings Row.
Okay, das ist ein ganz klares
Theme, so nach dem Motto, es ist ein futuristisches
London. Also sprich,
das, das sieht stimmig
aus, wohingegen die meisten
Valorant-Maps eher so aussehen,
als hat man die,
als hat man Räume aneinander geordnet
und
zwischendrin mal Räume, wo man
die Decke weggelassen hat.
So ungefähr sehen
Valorant-Maps aus. Die sehen
nicht aus wie ein natürliches Gebiet,
was
zwar vielleicht der Spielbarkeit
wegen nicht ganz realistisch ist, aber
irgendwie einen sinnvollen,
ein sinnvolles Setting vermittelt.
Die Valorant-Maps sehen halt
wirklich so aus, als hat man sich erstmal
ein halbwegs spielbares Layout überlegt
und dann wusste man nicht, wie man
das
in eine sinnvolle Thematik einbinden kann.
Es ist, es ist, es ist schwierig.
Ich kann's, ihr wisst, ich weiß nicht,
vielleicht täuscht das auch als Zuschauer,
aber Valorant-Maps sehen halt für mich auch so aus.
Raum, Raum, Raum,
Gang, Raum, wo man die Decke
weggelassen hat, Raum, Raum,
also das ist alles sehr, auf der einen Seite
sehr rechteckig, alles, und
unlogisch zusammen.
Also du, du läufst
dann erst durch nen, du läufst dann erst durch
nen Gang, wo irgendwie ein großes Tor ist,
was aussieht wie von ner Industrieanlage
und auf einmal stehst du, obwohl
da nicht mal ne Eingangstür ist, sondern was in nem
Wohnzimmer, was dann aber nicht weitergeht,
was aber ein großes Fenster auf den Bomben-Spot
hat oder so.
Das ist zwar in CS
auch so, aber in
CS, die haben den Vorteil,
die haben die meisten Maps wenigstens so'n bisschen,
weiß ich,
entweder sowas wie das, so'n bisschen in außen
gelegene Region, oder industriemäßig
sowas wie Cache gemacht, da ergibt's
noch irgendwie Sinn, dass da Lagerhaus
in Lagerhalle und
Luftschacht und so geht, das passt
schon, aber wenn ich mal beispielsweise
Valorant, ich weiß nicht, wie die Map heißt,
die hat so ne, die hat, vielleicht wisst ihr's, die hat so
die hat Wüste, die hat so'n Wüste-Wüste-Tag
Textur, Boden,
und du läufst durch so'ne Art
Dusche oder, oder Bad
vom Spawn zum Bombenpunkt auf der
rechten Seite. Da pieken
die Leute auch immer in dieses Bad rein,
oder Bad, Dusche, ich weiß nicht, was
das ist, das ist irgendwie,
es sieht aus, als hätt's so'n gekachelt, so'n gekachelten
Raum, so, und da denk ich mir
immer so, okay, das passt thematisch da
null hin, das ist nen Gang,
nen Gang, nen Ding, und
dann Bomben-Spot, wo man den, den,
den Skybox oben drauf
gepappt, also, es
passt irgendwie nicht so richtig zusammen. Ist das
Bind? Moment, Moment.
Ja, genau die mein ich, ja.
Genau.
Genau. Ah, Garden nennt sich
das, Garden nennt sich das.
Ah, Moment, das ist Defender, ich mein Attacker, das, das hier,
Bad, das heißt tatsächlich Bad.
Okay, wenigstens, wenigstens
man hat das als Bad erkannt.
Das, das bin ich ja schon mal froh, ich wusste nicht, dass das
Bad heißt. Ähm,
genau, und ich finde, das ist übrigens
noch eine der, der, wie soll ich sagen,
besser zusammenpassenden
Maps in Valorant, rein aus Zuschauersicht
jetzt, by the way, ne, ich, ich, ich spiel das nicht.
Aber, aber, man sieht schon, das ist alles
extrem, extrem rechteckig,
so nach dem Motto, Raum,
Raum, Raum, und hier hat man dann
gesagt, okay, hier ist ne Halle, und hier ist ein Raum,
warum ist denn hier eigentlich die Decke weg?
Warum? Warum ist hier die Decke weg?
So nach dem Motto. Das ergibt irgendwie alles
wenig zusammenhängenden
Sinn in diesem Setting.
Aber das ist auch eines der besseren Maps, also ich
finde, die, die Valorant Level, die
Designer müssten sich mal bisschen
Inspiration holen von anderen Games,
dass man auch gute Maps bauen kann,
die ein stimmiges Setting haben,
was in irgendeiner Art und Weise
ähm, plausibel erscheint.
Das ist das, was ich meine, ja? Die, die,
die Overwatch Maps haben auch viele
Gameplay-technische Probleme, aber
die sind wenigstens
ähm,
plausibel vom Aufbau her irgendwie.
Der Lead-Designer hat
Cache erstellt. Ja, ungefähr so
sehen die Maps ja auch aus, nur dass es bei
Cache passt,
weil Cache Industriegebiet ist.
Cache ist auch so ne Map, wo man gesagt
hat, Viereck an Viereck an Viereck an
Luftschacht dazwischen, nur
mit dem Unterschied, dass es bei Cache
irgendwie dank Industriegebiet noch halbwegs
passt. Aber Bind ist ja so
ein Zwischending aus, man weiß was,
wo, was soll Bind eigentlich
darstellen als Valorant Map?
Ist es, das ist ja auch das Ding, das ist
so ein bisschen Vorstadt oder sowas, keine
Ahnung, aber es ergibt keinen Sinn.
Was soll das eigentlich sein? Du hast
Wohnhäuser, die keine Häuser sind,
du hast irgendwelche komischen
offenen Flächen, dann hast du nen Bad
zwischendrin. Keine Ahnung!
Das ergibt einfach keinen Sinn.
Sieht nach nem Industriepark aus.
Ja, aber warum hast du dann auf einmal nen Bad
zwischendrin?
Oder, warum hast du
auf einmal nen Wohnzimmer? Wie nennt sich das
Wohnzimmer eigentlich in den Callouts?
Sekunde. Wie nennt sich das Wohnzimmer?
Window. Okay.
Das ist ein Wohnzimmer, was auf einmal hier random
drinne ist in der Map. Hier.
Das ist einfach, das hier ist einfach nen Wohnzimmer
random. Das ist einfach
ein Wohnzimmer, zwischendrinne irgendwie.
Okay.
Ja, das da mein ich.
Spielbar ist die Map sicherlich nicht
schlecht, ja. Aber
gesamtmäßig
sieht's einfach nicht stimmig aus.
Und das ist noch eines der besseren Maps.
Rein vom
Zuschauen her.
Okay, Chat, es muss anscheinend wirklich was dran sein,
dass das in dem Space,
dass JV Peak in den Spacebox-Videos
am Start ist.
Der natürlich, er hat natürlich nichts damit zu tun,
logischerweise, ja.
Also es wäre möglich, dass er sich vielleicht
für solche Themen
auch interessiert.
...
station 5 exclusive later this year but speculation suggests it's either secretly
being developed by hideo kojima or is a was ich habe ich noch okay ich bin ich
bin outdated was ist das new silent hill title both rumors have been shot down by
the game's developers multiple times but they recently tweeted a blurry image of
a man with an eyepatch and big boss aka snake real time experience kojima does
sport and I patched ist es die schau mal nicht in java programmiert
ansehen also opiert an podcast sponsored by konami who owns the rights to the silent hill
franchise they have since updated the promotions for the bodkast twice the first are interchange
the sponsor team über team das sorgen für attik blue team and konami bevor wir
getour final story des wikileaks eu saying thank you for tuning in we hope you enjoy
dvd-serien lasst uns gerne spielen lasst uns gerne sehen wir sehen uns nächste woche
von Level Cap, alles klar.
So, was gucken wir uns jetzt als nächstes an?
Das Freedom Phone.
Okay, das gucken wir uns jetzt an. Das hat jemand im Chat
gepostet.
Ich gucke ab und zu mal Videos von ihm,
wobei ich sagen muss, manche Einstellungen
sind mir zu...
Ich glaube nicht, dass man radikal sagen kann, aber
irgendwie zu Realitäts...
inkompatibel.
So, gucken wir uns
das mal an. Freedom Phone.
Was zum Geil ist
das Free... Das muss ich jetzt mal angucken.
Freedom Phone.
Kekona Time. Freedom Phone.
Oh.
Was? Ah, ich bin
kein DDoS-Angreifer. Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Schau es dir einfach an.
Meinst du, er zeigt da genug? Ja, gucken wir uns an.
Gutes.
On Vag-cation.
Go to the first page
of their website, freedomphone.com.
Kekona.
And you see, we have an animation of old glory
here. Natürlich.
In big, bold, white letters, it says
Freedom Phone. Completely uncensored.
And to give you a little bit of background,
the creation of this phone... Ich muss sagen,
dieses Emote passt da unglaublich
gut hin, als würde es in der Seite schon
standardmäßig drin sein.
...actually inspired by the shenanigans that took place
over the past maybe two
years in burger politics.
So, you know, all of those
anomalies that happened with the election
and then the QAnon-Shaman-Friends
went and stormed the Capitol because they
really wanted to use Nancy Pelosi's
phone to make a call to the
Base Department. But there's just one problem
with that. Just Kekona
things. Feds are
cringe, and so are Fed
phones, and you can't call the
Base Department with them because the Base Department
... Was spricht der überhaupt? Ich kann ihm nicht folgen.
... blocks cringe numbers.
Now, after
that was all over, Google
and Apple both decided to ban
the Parler app from their
app stores, which is basically just conservative
Twitter. Was? Hä?
Ich komm nicht mal mit, das ist mir zu viel.
... a lot of these people met up at.
And so that's when the big tech
exodus really kicked off
and this guy, Eric Finman,
created the Freedom Phone
that would be uncensorable and
respect your privacy. Okay.
So let's see what this Bitcoin
millionaire... By the way, wisst ihr, was
auch sinnvoll ist, einfach verschlüsselten
Messenger verwenden. Da kann auch keiner
so wirklich was sensoren.
... done, as far as developing
a phone. Außer, außer,
außer, Moment, Moment, außer
der Hersteller liefert
in seinem Betriebssystem irgendwelche
Texterkennung aus oder so, was es
anzeigt. Ja, vielleicht, aber
ich glaube, das ist erstmal nicht, wo man
sich unmittelbar Gedanken drüber machen muss.
... the TLDR right now. It's a
marked up China phone
with a de-googled
Android Chrome installed on it.
China-Chinesen-Phone.
De-googling an Android Chrome
Also ein China-Phone klingt ja schon mal
extrem nach Freedom.
... not equal creating your own operating
system. But that's exactly what they're claiming
down here. They say that they
have a free speech-first operating
system called Freedom OS.
We've developed the first mass-marketable
mobile phone operating system
based on free speech. Also eine Sache kann man
sich ja schon mal merken. Wenn irgendwie
was so branding-technisch
komplett auf so eine Sache
hinzieht, dann stimmt das meistens nicht.
Das ist genauso, wie wenn dir irgendein
Coach erzählt, werde reich in
einer Woche. Das ist
auch Schwachsinn. Also alles, was so
komplett in eine Richtung zielt und alles
darauf getrimmt ist, ist meistens nicht
so.
... can do that. This is still
Android. It's not like they created
something other than Android or
iOS or even, you know, Linux.
... der Tempel-OS nehmen können.
Und portieren auf Arm.
It's literally
just Android with all of the
stock Google stuff removed.
Okay, this is stupider than the kids
who go install Arch Linux and then
rice their desktop and say, look, mommy,
I made my own operating system.
I'm a hacker, man.
It's not rocket science to de-Google
Android. In fact, there's ROMs
that are already de-Googled for you.
So this guy probably just
added like some branding and skins
to one of those. Was ist denn jetzt eigentlich
so dieser Haupt-Selling-Point von dieser Geschichte?
Dass er sagt, es ist
unzensierbar.
Das stimmt ja überhaupt nicht. Spätestens von ihm
ist es zensierbar, wenn es einen zentralen
App-Store und zentrale Update-Server
gibt.
Also unzensierbar ergibt ja in dem Fall schon mal
gar keinen Sinn.
... created my own OS
and I run Gentoo with a custom kernel.
Now, honestly...
Das weiß ich. Er ist ja da schon
ziemlich hart drauf. Also ich würde mir
im Leben kein Gentoo holen, wo ich dann
erst mal, wenn ich einen E-Mail-Anhang
bekomme, den ich nicht öffnen kann,
zwei Stunden was kompilieren muss. Aber je...
Jeder wie er will.
... honestly hope that FreedomOS
really is just something
like LineageOS with like some
conservative social media pre-install.
Because like you can see, they got Rumble
and Newsmax and Parler
and I don't even know what this is.
Da waren die Leute, jetzt muss ich jetzt mal
unterbrechen, da waren die Leute
in meinem vorletzten Video total überrascht.
Ich habe ja gesagt, dass es unter iOS
keinen anderen Browser als Safari gibt.
Natürlich gab es wieder die üblichen Diskussionen,
aber da hat jemand einen Kommentar geschrieben,
wie ist das... Ne, der hat gesagt,
du hast den DuckDuckGo-Browser
vergessen. Das kann doch kein Safari
sein. So in der Richtung hat er das geschrieben.
Da habe ich mir gedacht, okay.
Ja doch.
Ja doch. Ist es.
Da ging das ganze Video noch drum.
DuckDuckGo.
I really hope that that's what
FreedomOS actually is, because
if this guy actually
did go and create his own
mobile operating system or like, you know,
try to create his own mobile OS
with the Android kernel,
he's probably going to get absolutely
buttfucked by exploits.
Kommt da jetzt so irgendwas?
Ich meine, das ist ja nach einer Minute,
irgendein Typ hat gesagt, er bringt
einen Custom Android raus, was angeblich
nicht uncensorable ist.
Ja gut.
Das hat man ja schon nach 30 Sekunden erkannt,
dass er Schwachsinn ist.
Okay, Eric Finman, he doesn't really
have a tech background at all.
His parents basically just gave
him a thousand dollars
back when he was a teenager and Bitcoin
wasn't worth that much and he bought like
40 of them and now he's rich,
which is great. I mean, don't get me wrong.
It's really good. It's a really good
investment move, but it doesn't
really qualify him to build
a secure, private
mobile operating system.
Now let's go take a look at the specs.
Okay, so this is the
spec sheet for FreedomFoam,
which apparently they were...
Der Name macht mich immer noch fertig, Alter.
FreedomFoam mit FreedomOS.
Das ist so hardcore, Kekona.
Anders kann ich das gar nicht mehr beschreiben.
Apparently they didn't even add this
until like last Monday or something like that
because they were trying to keep it
under watch.
Aber eigentlich sollte das doch als Hintergrund
wenigstens mal eine MP5 oder sowas haben.
Oder wobei MP5 ist noch zu deutsch.
Eine M4 ist doch so typisch
Ami-Stelz, oder?
Genau, Mr. Ami.
Eine M4 würde ich jetzt auch sagen.
Das wäre doch so ein typisches Ami-Ding.
So.
Überlegt euch mal, dann könnte man das auch
super customisable...
customisen. Du machst dann
mit einer AK bringst du
das russische OS raus, mit einer MP5
bringst du das German OS raus
und mit einer M4 bringst du
halt dann das Freedom Kekona OS raus.
Das wäre doch was.
Alright, keep that in mind as we look through
these specifications.
Hier ist kein 20-Monat-Anstieg für den Sub.
Cameras, so
front is 8 megapixel, rear is
13, and then there's also a 2 and a 2.
I think that's what it means.
So three cameras on the back.
Um, and none of them are really...
Da muss ich sagen, bei so Kamera-Bezeichnungen
blick ich eh nicht mehr durch.
Ich glaub, das heißt front 8 megapixel, rear 13 plus 2 plus 2...
Aber hä?
Da blick ich noch, das ist mir zu viel.
But then again, you know, $500 isn't like flagship price anyway.
Aber trotzdem, aber trotzdem,
500 Dollar für ein Smartphone finde ich immer noch ordentlich.
Ich weiß, heute ist das Standard, aber
ich finde eigentlich 500 Dollar, 500 Dollar,
können jetzt fast in Euro umdingsen,
immer noch einen ordentlichen Preis für ein Gerät, ja?
It doesn't have giant bezels, although
by today's standards, these are pretty big bezels.
We have the display resolution, so it's not even full HD.
Okay, Auflösung ist nicht der Wahnsinn.
On CPU, they omit the kind of CPU.
Ja, was ist das für eine CPU?
You know, like whether it's a Snapdragon or a Zenos,
or you know, which version of it it is.
All we know is that it's 1.8 GHz in 8 cores, which...
Ja, okay.
...to a Tera 5 or the Pine phone,
but at least those phones have...
Okay, im Prinzip ist das relativ nichtssagend,
weil die ersten 30 Sekunden ist eigentlich schon alles gesagt,
es ist Schwachsinn.
Und ja, es bleibt weiterhin Schwachsinn.
...does give the Freedom Phone its worth.
What gives it its value?
Ja, nix.
And then how much is the hardware
for the Freedom Phone actually worth?
Moment, warum ist da Brave drauf?
Hatten sie nicht eben noch Dr. Go Browser gezeigt?
Well, it's worth about 100...
Vor allem, vor allem...
Was ist denn das?
Was ist das?
Was ist das, Tiermann?
Kamera?
Whatsapp?
Ne, Whatsapp ist es nicht, oder?
Ah, Signal, Signal ist es.
Signal und Telegramm drauf.
Also, wenn doch super krass private,
dann sollte es gleich Threema sein.
Oder wie spricht man das aus?
Dreema? Threema? Sreema?
Was ist denn sonst noch so drauf?
Erkennt man nicht.
...phone actually worth.
Well, it's worth about...
It's worth about a hundred and thirty nine dollars.
So, this...
Umidigi.
Umidigi Smartphone ist das, alles klar.
Die weltbekannte, der weltbekannte Hersteller Umidigi.
Digi, Alter, Digi.
Digga, Mann.
Umidigi.
This is the same exact phone.
The, um, Umigi, not really...
Ach, Umidgi, Umidgi.
A9 Pro Smartphone.
It's got the exact same hardware.
Same camera.
Like, this is literally the same phone
as the Freedom Phone.
Was zum...
Wie viele Kameras haben die da dran?
What the fuck?
Moment, Moment.
Wie viele habe ich eigentlich am iPhone dran?
Zeig mal her.
Zwei.
Also, ich habe hier ein iPhone 11.
Das hat zwei.
Okay, okay.
Man könnte sagen, es hat auch vier so Dinger.
Ich weiß aber ehrlich gesagt nicht, was es ist.
Ich...
Also, ich glaube, das eine ist der Blitz, oder?
Warte mal.
Ich kenne von meinem iPhone 11...
Ich weiß ja nicht mal, welche Kamera was ist.
So, so sieht das aus hier.
So sieht das aus.
Also, das sind wahrscheinlich...
Warum habe ich überhaupt zwei Kameras?
Normal und Weitwinkel.
Ah, ja.
Siehste mal.
Das ist der Blitz, oder?
Und das ist irgendein Infrarotding?
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Zoom?
Kein Schimmer.
Ich weiß bis heute nicht, warum ein Telefon mehr als zwei Kameras hat.
Keine Ahnung.
Kein Schimmer.
Das ist der Blitz, oder?
Vermute ich mal.
Das...
Das ist ein Mikrofon?
Das ist doch kein Mikrofon.
Kann tatsächlich ein Mikrofon sein.
Das ist ein Mikrofon, Leute.
Jetzt...
Ich gucke da zum ersten Mal rein.
Das ist ein Mikrofon.
Nice.
Was...
Was es nicht alles gibt.
Siehste mal, wie gut ich über mein Smartphone Bescheid weiß.
Okay, next.
Aber warum hat das sechs Dinger?
Okay, Blitz.
Blitz.
Was geht da?
Mega Pixel AI Kamera.
Alles klar.
Freedom.
Na ja, gut.
Es ist ja auch Freedom.
Freiheit kostet halt Geld.
Ja, ja.
Ja.
Social Media, that they have
installed here, you know, Parler,
and then like Telegram, man, I wouldn't really
consider that a conservative thing,
but you know, Telegram,
Newsmax,
Signal, Brave,
these are all free apps,
that they're just installing for you,
and even if you're like, oh,
but those are blocked in the App Store,
you can sideload apps on Android, that has
always been a thing.
Ja, im Vergleich zu
iOS, und bevor jetzt jemand
kommt, ja, ich weiß, man kann unter iOS
auch sideloaden, aber das ist
pain in the ass zu sideloaden
unter iOS.
Sei denn, du hast gejailbraked.
iOS sideloaden ist
nach sieben Tagen, glaube,
bin mir nicht ganz sicher, aber ist nach
sieben Tagen, also es geht nach einer gewissen Zeit
wieder weg, das was du
drauf sideloadest, es sei denn,
du hast irgendwie ein gültiges Entwicklerzertifikaten
bezahlt, irgendwie 150 Euro im
Quartal oder so an Apple.
Ich weiß die Einzelheiten nicht genau,
aber so ähnlich ist es.
Es ist eklig, das ist
unter Android deutlich angenehmer.
Okay, also
das Video...
Ah, yes, selling patriotic
goods made in China to low
IQ Americans,
it really...
Okay, alles klar.
Was auch immer, was auch immer.
Also man hätte nach 30 Minuten eigentlich schon sagen
können, nach 30 Sekunden eigentlich schon
sagen können, ja, ist halt sinnlos.
Okay, der
Algorithmus kriegt noch einmal
eine Chance.
Nein, gibt nix.
Hier, zähl mal bitte die Kameras.
Sekunde.
Was ist das denn?
Was ist denn das?
Was?
Das ist doch
ein Fake, oder?
Das kannst du doch nicht stehen, ja?
Das...
Das ist doch kein...
Nein, das ist doch ein Fake, oder?
Ist das wirklich so?
What the fuck?
Was kostet das?
Ah, das ist schon
zwei Jahre alt. Warum?
Was?
Why?
Das sieht aus wie irgendein
Fantasy-Gegner aus einem RPG.
Der kommt so auf dich
zugeflogen in irgendeinem dunklen Dungeon.
Das leuchtet dann hier noch.
Rot oder so.
Okay, was war jetzt genau
der Verkaufspunkt?
Also, warum genau sollte man sich das jetzt
kaufen? Ich meine, wegen den Kameras kaufe ich
doch kein Smartphone.
Ich kaufe mir ein Smartphone und natürlich,
wenn ich die Auswahl habe zwischen was mit einer guten
Kamera und einer schlechten Kamera, nehme ich das mit einer guten Kamera.
Und wenn es für mich wichtig ist,
ab und zu mal ordentliche Bilder zu machen, dann kaufe
ich vielleicht auch ein teureres. Aber wenn ich mir
ein Foto kaufen will, dann ist das...
Wenn ich was fotografieren will, dann ist es doch immer besser,
ich kaufe mir einen ordentlichen Fotograf,
anstatt irgendeinen Smartphone mit 150 Kameras.
Die Software dazu war
super pro und hat es nicht geschafft, die Bilder
zusammensetzen. Okay, da freuen sich sicherlich alle,
die das gekauft haben, wahnsinnig drüber.
Guter Reaction-Content.
Vielleicht gucken wir uns das nachher
noch an.
Alter,
was war das für ein Intro?
Ja, da macht er eigentlich gute Videos, der Typ.
Hat der eigentlich mal wieder ein neues Video?
Ähm,
äh,
ne wie hieß das?
Kakweh vs.
vs.
äh,
wie hieß das Video? Das war ein richtig gutes Video von dem.
Kakweh vs. Lulve.
Genau. Das Video
ist einfach zu gut.
Das gucken wir jetzt aber nicht, aber das ist echt nice.
Also,
für Leute, die viel auf Twitch sind,
jeder andere, jeder andere
wird sich wahrscheinlich denken, äh, wer guckt sich
so einen Scheiß an, aber ja, für Leute, die auf Twitch
sind, ist das nice.
So, also.
Was, was, was können wir uns jetzt angucken?
So, ja, den, den, den gucken wir uns an.
Der ist, vor, vor ist Binding.
Jawohl.
Kekona-Lock.
Sekunde, ich muss kurz Musik ausmachen.
Ne, nicht Kekona, Kekonadot-Lock ist es.
Wie, wie viel kostet das?
13, 13 Rubel.
13 Rubel-Schloss, exzellent.
Er hat doch, er hat doch sicherlich den, den Special, den Special-Kekonadot-Lock-Pick.
Er hat doch alles an Hardware, was man braucht, um Schleuser zu knacken.
Wenn's nicht ausreicht, dann einfach mal dreimal so lang.
Oder zehnmal so lang.
Ich muss ein bisschen mehr spezifisch sein.
Wir saßen runter und kamen mit diesen mit.
Also, neue Werkzeuge in der Hand.
Mal sehen, wie lange es dauert, um das zu öffnen.
Klick-Auto vor, vor ist Binding.
Die übliche Geschichte jetzt.
Five-Hat-Time angesagt.
Ach ne.
Okay, da ist ein Pick.
Easy, easy.
Zwei Picks.
Man muss gar nichts machen, außer wackeln.
Und nur um einen ungenannten Ingenieur
zurück bei Covert Instruments Headquarters zu halten,
werden wir diesen extra langen Mann benutzen.
Und Pick Nr. 3.
Easy, easy, putty, easy, putty.
Okay, Folks, that's all I have for you today.
I hope you enjoyed this vlog.
If you do have any...
Der hat, der hat ein richtig gutes Konzept für seinen Channel.
Er hat quasi mit dieser Thematik, und er hat's ja auch drauf,
er hat nahezu unendlich Content.
Ich mein, Schlösser,
ich mein, geh nur mal in irgendeinen Laden
und guck mal, was ist für Schlösser.
Du findest Milliarden Schlösser.
Der kann bis, bis er,
selbst wenn er 500 Jahre alt wird,
könnte der jeden Tag einen Video machen.
Ein Video hochladen mit einem anderen Schloss.
Questions or Comments about it,
please put them below.
If you like this video and would like to see more like it,
please subscribe.
And as always, have a nice day.
Thank you.
Der Tag eines ITlers.
Eines Fachinformatikers
Systemintegration.
Okay, Einleitung.
So sieht das bei uns aber nett aus.
Diese Stockfotos, ne?
Aber das ist tatsächlich, vielleicht ist das doch bei ihm.
Ich hätte jetzt gesagt, das ist ein Stockfoto.
Aber die,
diese, oder diese Stockvideos,
gibt es Stockvideos?
Das sieht immer so, so hell
und freundlich aus
und die Leute, und die Leute
sitzen immer da und sind so
konzentriert und machen was,
so wie das in der Realität halt überhaupt nicht aussieht.
Ja, Open Spaces sind Painstamp, das stimmt.
Was ich übrigens witzig finde,
dass, ähm,
man bei Google was,
glaube ich, schon vor ein paar Jahren erkannt hat,
dass,
wenn man alles in offene
und, und wild wechselbare
Arbeitsplätze packt, das nicht
gerade förderlich ist für die Leute
zum Konzentrieren. Also, man hat es,
man hat es schon vor einer Weile gemerkt, dass es keine allzu
gute Idee ist. Und
jetzt, ich weiß ja, wir sind,
wir sind, also da wo ich arbeite, wir sind ja
umgezogen vor
vier, fünf Jahren oder so.
Vor vier Jahren, glaube ich, sind wir umgezogen.
Und,
dort hat man das dann angepriesen,
als die super neue Errungenschaft,
dass es jetzt mehr
Großraumbüros gibt.
Und da habe ich mir damals schon gedacht, was eine bescheuerte Idee.
Was eine bescheuerte Idee.
Und jetzt ist es darauf rausgelaufen, es gibt jetzt
quasi Großraumbüros
und es gibt so an jeder Ecke mal
eins, zwei, drei kleinere,
ähm,
ja, Büros.
Es sind ja keine wirklichen Büros, im Prinzip ist das einfach nur
ein Schreibtisch und zwei Stühle dran.
Genau, das sind Trinktanks, sind das.
Wie wir das finden, es wird auch als Thinktank
verkauft bei uns. Und das läuft
dann eigentlich so, dass
jeder, der in einem Büro sitzt, wo
sagen wir mal,
mehr besetzt ist, als
jeder zweite Tisch, der geht
einfach morgens in so
einen Thinktank und kommt den ganzen Tag
dann mal raus.
Das heißt, man hat das quasi ausgeleitet.
Das ist total bescheuert, das ergibt
überhaupt keinen Sinn.
So, und nachdem das die Leute jetzt machen,
weil sie ihre Ruhe haben wollen,
sind natürlich die Thinktanks nicht mehr frei
für
das, wofür sie eigentlich gedacht waren,
dass man sich spontan mal treffen
kann, wenn man über irgendwelche
Dinge nachdenken will oder irgendwie
sich mal kurzschließen will oder
was auch immer. Dann hast du keinen Platz mehr. Das heißt,
du musst jetzt für solche Sachen offizielles
Meeting wieder eintragen in den Meetingraum
und dementsprechend sind auch keine
Meetingräume mehr frei. Und das
alles nur wegen Großraumbüros.
Bei uns,
Moment, Chat, Chat
sagt, bei uns wurden
Wände nachgesetzt. Das hat man bei uns
nicht gemacht. Was man bei uns jetzt
versucht hat ist, weil
es eben Abfuck war, man hat so
Stoff,
keine Ahnung, so
Schallschutzwände
hat man, also keine
richtigen Wände, man hat so Schallschutzwände
nachträglich in die Räume
getragen und dort aufgestellt.
Aber die sind halt leicht, die kann man auch rum
schieben.
Ja, da kann man auch als Pinwand
benutzen, genau.
Ja, dann hast du so Lärmschutzwände,
die kannst du dann quasi rumschieben im Raum.
Total bescheuert, das weiß ich nicht. Aber
juckt mich nicht, ich bin seit
jetzt seit März
2000, äh nee, nee, nee,
2020, nicht 2000, oder?
Wann ging Corona los?
2020, oder?
Ja.
Ich bin seit März 2020 jetzt im Dauer-Homeoffice.
Da juckt mich das nicht und
ich hab jetzt auch endlich, hat das
jetzt funktioniert auf der Arbeit, ich hab jetzt
auch mein, äh, meine Arbeitszeit,
meine Arbeitszeit ändern lassen, also
das, das, ähm,
wie nennt man das, Arbeitszeitmodell
von, ich bin ja eh nur noch 4 Tage am Start, schon
immer, also immer, die letzten 7
Jahre oder so, arbeite ich hier nur 4 Tage
die Woche und, äh, ich hab's
jetzt endlich ändern lassen von,
oder beantragt, dass es zum, glaub,
1., 1.9. oder so
geändert wird, dass ich mehr, mehr Homeoffice
standardmäßig, ja,
so muss das sein.
Homeoffice-Beste, ich bin seitdem viel wacher,
ich bin fitter, ich hab weniger
Rückenschmerzen, ich hab ihn, äh,
kann mich besser konzentrieren, es ist eigentlich
alles besser, ohne Scheiß, für
mich ist alles besser, äh,
seit Homeoffice, und für
die Firma ist dementsprechend, was ich mache,
auch besser. Bin doch immer noch auf
80 Prozent. 4 Tage
die Woche von 5. Okay,
also, der Tag eines
ITlers, Alltag eines Fachinformatikers
für Systemintegration, das gucken wir uns
jetzt mal an, vielleicht, wir skippen ein bisschen
zwischendurch, weil ich weiß nicht, ob das, äh,
wie, vielleicht sind ja manche Teile nicht so
spannend, da kann ich nämlich gut was zu
sagen, das ist das, was ich auch paar Jahre
lang, so oder so ähnlich, äh, geh ich mal
voll aus, je nachdem, was kommt.
Druckerproblem? Telefonproblem?
Druckerproblem? Monks?
Ne, das hab ich nicht
gemacht.
Ich war, ich war Turnschuhatmen im Rechenzentrum.
Quasi.
Evgeni!
So, zeig her.
Zeig her.
Ich muss mal meine Emotes
oben positionieren.
Falsches Emote.
Ja.
Auf geht's.
Und das ist eben auch das, was ihr in Zukunft vielleicht auch machen werdet,
wenn ihr aktuell eine Ausbildung macht, beispielsweise.
Ich hoffe, ich hoffe, niemand muss
Druckerprobleme beheben.
Oder wenn ihr
überlegt, eine Ausbildung anzufangen.
Natürlich gibt es in der IT zahlreiche Bereiche,
in die ihr euch orientieren könnt. Ja.
Und wo ihr euch hin entwickeln könnt.
Und nahezu unendlich viele, ja. Das ist nur ein Bereich, den ich euch zeigen möchte.
Nahezu unendlich ist so eine bescheuerte
Redewendung, die, die mathematisch
auch wenig, wenig Sinn ergibt, ne.
Entweder ist es unendlich oder nicht.
Nahezu unendlich.
Das ist quasi so die Umschreibung.
Es ist sehr viel.
Wobei unendlich ja auch nicht gleich unendlich ist, ja.
Du hast immer noch
abzählbare unendliche Reihen.
Du hast aber auch welche, die sind nicht abzählbar.
Unendlich plus eins, ja.
Und minus eins.
Und wir haben hier mehrere Hallen
und da drin sind auch PCs
und Drucker und alles mögliche.
Hacker Man. Hacker Man Time.
Ja, so komische Dinge haben wir auch, ja.
Wir haben hier auch ein
Verwaltungsgebäude, da sind auch ganz normale Arbeitsplätze
aufgebaut, ganz normale Büroplätze
und wir haben hier vor Ort eine breite Palette
aus Hardware und Software und demnach
ist mein Arbeitsalltag durchaus abwechslungsreich.
Es gibt immer verschiedene Sachen
zu erledigen.
Da wir hier nur eine kleine IT-Abteilung haben,
bin ich hier auch für alle Aufgaben zuständig, also den
First Level, Second Level und letztendlich
auch den Third Level. Es gibt zwar noch einige
Dienstleistungen... Was muss man lernen,
um in die IT-Sicherheit zu kommen?
Naja, das mag
sich jetzt dumm anhören, aber um in
die IT-Sicherheit zu kommen, musst du IT-Sicherheit
lernen. Logisch.
Oder?
Also...
Was soll
ich da sonst zu sagen?
Ähm...
Ja, was muss
man lernen, um in die IT-Sicherheit...
Du musst dich mit IT-Security-Themen
auskennen.
Und nachdem IT-Security jetzt nicht
ein Thema ist, musst du dich
halt in dem Bereich auskennen. Und natürlich auch im besten
in dem Bereich, was dann später gebraucht wird.
Das kann von Netzwerktechnik
sein, das kann was mit Viren,
Malware, sonst was zu tun haben.
Irgendwelche Penetration-Tests,
alles mögliche.
Hacker-Kram, ja.
Das kann man
pauschal nicht auf ein Thema
eingrenzen. Aber ja, um in
IT-Sicherheit was
zu machen, muss man sich mit IT-
Sicherheit auskennen. Weil ich meine,
warum sollte man einen IT-Security-Mensch einstellen,
der keine Ahnung von IT-Security hat?
Habt ihr das gelesen?
Mit Blizzard und den
Penetration-Tests.
Diese Musik klingt so, wie bei einem Code steht.
Das ist Mario-Beach-Musik.
Also Blizzard, Blizzard und
Penetration-Tests. Habe ich gestern gelesen. Hat sich jemand
beschwert. Eine
Security... Weiß ich gar nicht,
was sie ist. Ähm... Keine Ahnung.
Ähm...
Security-Expertin. Ja, sag ich jetzt mal.
Auf irgendeiner Hacker-Konferenz.
Ähm... Hat einen Job
gesucht und ist zu
Blizzard an den
Stand. Und
ähm...
Da wurde sie dann gefragt,
ob sie...
Da wurde sie irgendwas von
Penetration-Tests
wurden erzählt. Und dann hat
das Blizzard,
das Blizzard Recruiting Squad,
was da auf der
Messe oder auf dieser Veranstaltung,
auf dieser Konferenz war, hat sie dann
gefragt, ob sie mal penetriert werden will.
Also Blizzard
verkackt es wirklich aktuell auf ganzer
Linie. Das ist aber auch schon eine Weile her. Das war
2015 oder so.
Aber was bei Blizzard
los ist, ist echt der Wahnsinn.
Jetzt feiert das mal nicht so ab, Chat.
Ich kann mir
vorstellen, dass es in der Situation echt
unangenehm war. Stellt euch
mal vor, ihr geht irgendwo hin, weil ihr
vielleicht, weil ihr einen Job sucht. Da ist
irgend so ein Recruiting Squad am Start.
Ihr redet über irgendwelche Hacker-Sachen.
Du wirst nicht komplett ernst genommen.
Und dann wirst du noch so dumme Dinger gefragt,
wie, willst du mal penetriert
werden?
Also, das wäre
mir äußerst unangenehm.
Auch als
Kerl wäre mir das äußerst unangenehm.
Und als Frau kann ich mir vorstellen, ist das einem noch
unangenehmer. Das mag
sein, weiß ich, kann ich nichts zu...
Kann sein, kann sein, dass sie das anhat.
Aber trotzdem, wenn ich dort als
offizieller
Recruiter-Dude hingehe,
selbst wenn jemand ein etwas
sagen wir mal so, wie soll ich sagen,
einladenden
Spruch auf dem T-Shirt hat,
darüber einen Witz zu machen,
dann sollte man sich das als
Recruiter-Dude verkneifen, darüber
unanständige Witze zu machen.
Unabhängig davon, was auf dem T-Shirt
draufsteht. Dann sollte man
zumindest, man kann sich das ja
denken, man kann auch sagen,
ich glaube, da stimmt die Chemie nicht,
dich wollen wir nicht oder so.
Okay, aber ich würde
insofern so den professionellen
Anschein wahren und keine dummen
Witze drüber machen. Immer mit
Voice Recorder.
Ja, das habe ich letztens gelesen,
da habe ich auch gedacht, ah, das ist PainsChamp, PainsChamp.
Auch wenn, selbst wie gesagt,
auch wenn sie so ein T-Shirt anhatte und
vielleicht manchem so als
der erste Gedanke
ist, so einen blöden Spruch zu machen, gerade
als offizieller Entsandter von einer
Firma als Recruiter dahin, würde
ich mir solche Sprüche im Leben nicht erlauben.
Genau,
wenn du mit der ganz Dicke bist,
wenn du mit den Leuten befreundet bist, da kannst du natürlich
so einen doofen Spruch bringen, aber nicht als
Recruiter von einer Firma, die da ist als
Sponsor und
da quasi als
professionelle Leute
auftreten, das kannst du nicht machen.
So, gucken wir mal weiter.
So, wir sind ja stehen geblieben eigentlich.
Hier, Fachinformatiker.
Also, wir waren jetzt bei Druckerpatronen.
... und sich auf bestimmte Bereiche spezialisieren,
beispielsweise die Telefonanlage oder... Wie findest du
ich jetzt denры und die repente?
G-Suite...
Jawohl, das sind
LC Stecker oder?
Das ist ein
SC Stecker und das
ein LC Stecater.
Kann das sein?
Ist auch egal.
Anfangen tut jeder meine Arbeitstage relativ gleich.
Finde ich interessant, dass sie das auch so unsinnig beschriftet haben.
Haben wir nämlich auch gemacht.
Bei uns sind die Server auch so unsinnig beschriftet, nur mit dem Unterschied.
Das darfst du eigentlich gar keinem erzählen.
Also das ist mittlerweile nicht mehr, das war bei uns so.
Vielleicht ist es bei denen ja auch intern sinnvoll, das Ganze so zu beschriften.
Also bei uns stand da auf den Servern drauf früher, was es ist.
Zum Beispiel Server 10.
Das Problem ist nur, dass dieses Etikett quasi immer vergessen wurde anzupassen,
wenn die Hardware für was anderes verwendet wurde.
Und dann hattest du Server letztens zum Beispiel.
Ich hatte erst letztens was.
Wir haben letztens einen Server gesucht.
Ich muss mir mal kurz mal etwas anonymisierten Namen ausdenken.
Wir haben einen Repo-Server gesucht letztens.
Und zwar folgendermaßen.
Das ist so der tägliche IT-Wahnsinn.
Den ich euch jetzt erzähle.
Das kennt wahrscheinlich jeder, der in diesem Bereich arbeitet.
Also irgendjemand vom Support hat gemeint, hey guckt mal, auf diesem System wurde schon lange kein Firmware-Update mehr gemacht.
So, dann hat er bei einem Admin angerufen.
Der Admin meint, ja, ist kein Thema.
Starte mir das Ding mal kurz neu, dass das Firmware-Update macht.
Nicht der Abfall-Server.
Ne, ne.
Starten wir mal kurz.
Das war irgendein Repo-Server.
Sollte er neu starten.
Er hat gesagt, ich starte das Ding mal kurz neu.
Das ist für den aktiven Betrieb nicht erforderlich.
Und ich starte das Ding mal neu im Firmware-Update und gut ist.
So, dann hat der Admin sich eingeloggt.
SSH neu gestartet.
Was passiert natürlich?
Server bootet nicht mehr.
Der Klassiker.
Reboot hängt.
Ist das schon mal der Klassiker.
Das kommt ja immer so.
So, und dann kam das Problem.
Der Server war nicht der richtige Server.
Also.
Wenn ein Server hängt, gehst du auf das Management-Interface und startest die Kiste neu.
Wenn du auf das Management-Interface gegangen bist, bist du auf einem NAS rausgekommen.
Auf einem NAS.
Auf einem komplett anderen, auf einem True-NAS bist du rausgekommen.
Ein komplett anderes System.
Und im FreeBSD True-NAS bist du rausgekommen, wenn du über das Management-Interface gegangen bist,
anstatt auf dem eigentlichen Linux-Repo-Server.
Das heißt, es war komplett falsch.
Das war einfach komplett falsch beschriftet.
Es stand halt in der Datenbank drin.
Hey.
Das Management-Interface für den Repo-Server ist die und die IP.
Bist du draufgegangen, kamst du auf einem True-NAS FreeBSD raus.
Und dann hatten wir das Problem.
Okay.
Erstens.
Der Server wurde komplett falsch neu gestartet.
Eigentlich wollte der Support-Mitarbeiter in Wirklichkeit das NAS neu starten für das Firmware-Update von der Hardware.
Weil ihm ging es ja um dieses eine Management-Interface, wovon man dachte,
der Server, den wir neu gestartet haben, der läuft da eigentlich drauf.
So.
Und dann kam aber das Nächste.
Wo läuft denn jetzt eigentlich dieser Server, der im Reboot hängt?
Das war ein Riesenakt.
Ein Riesenakt.
Irgendwann hat, ich habe das mitbekommen, weil mich der Admin angerufen hat, hat er gesagt,
sag mal, hast du irgendeine Ahnung, ob das noch irgendwo stehen kann?
Weil ich habe ein paar Dinger programmiert, die Infos sich aus den unterschiedlichsten Quellen zusammenziehen.
Das ist übrigens nicht auf Auftrag entstanden, sondern weil ich das selbst kacke fand.
Ich habe mir was programmiert, was aus mehreren Quellen unterschiedliche Daten,
Datenbanken, Web-Interfaces, sonst was, sich Informationen über Systeme zieht,
dass ich das schnell durchsuchen kann, weil ich keinen Bock habe, immer 50 Systeme zu durchsuchen.
Das ist bei uns kompletter Wildwuchs.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie das, dass das überhaupt funktioniert.
So.
Also hast du noch eine Idee?
Sag, ja, ich gucke mal.
Habe ich geguckt und das Erste, was ich gefunden habe, ist natürlich das Management-Interface,
was das Falsche ist.
Meint er, nee, nee, das ist es nicht.
Und da haben wir gesucht, haben wir gesucht, haben wir gesucht.
Und irgendwo habe ich dann gefunden, dass es gar kein Hardware-Server mehr ist,
sondern dass das jetzt ein Container ist, der auf irgendeinem noch nie dagewesenen,
noch nie gehörten Backend läuft.
Also es war eigentlich gar kein Hardware, also kein Server mehr auf Hardware,
es war schon irgendwas in Container gepacktes.
Und dann mussten wir das Backend suchen, wo das drauf läuft.
Dann haben wir erst nicht das Richtige gefunden,
weil es unter der Haube noch irgendwelche Synchronisationsdinger macht.
Ohne Scheiß, es hat zwei Stunden gedauert, bis wir den Scheiß gefunden haben.
Das ist wirklich...
So aus der Hölle gewesen wieder.
Deswegen, beschriftet eure Server ordentlich.
Es klingt erstmal unsinnig.
Ihr kennt das vielleicht so, gerade Management-Leute sagen das gerne,
so nach dem Motto, wieso, warum muss das alles so kleinlich beschriftet werden?
Wir haben doch eine Datenbank, wo das alles drinsteht.
Jaja, man hatte eine Datenbank, oder man hat eine Datenbank, wo das alles drinsteht.
Aber nachdem bei einem Update oder bei irgendeiner Änderung,
der Workflow eingehalten werden muss, und es an vielen Stellen Fehler passieren können,
dass einer irgendwo was vergisst, wirst du, früher oder später, egal wie ordentlich du bist,
wirst du immer wieder mal darauf treffen, dass einzelne Einträge in der Datenbank veraltet sind.
Weil irgendjemand, der das ausgebaut hat, das Falsche angeklickt hat, es vergessen hat, oder was auch immer.
Das heißt, das Einzige, was man wirklich machen kann, ist,
den Kram an mehreren Stellen beschriften, sodass du erkennen kannst,
am Ende ausschließen kannst, was falsch ist.
Ja, also wenn jetzt da Server 10 dran steht, im Webinterface steht Server 10 dran,
und in der anderen Datenbank steht drin, ah, das ist eigentlich gar nicht mehr Server 10,
dann hast du zumindest den Hinweis, okay, das war vielleicht mal Server 10,
aber jetzt ist es was anderes. Wisst ihr, wie ich meine?
Es schadet auf gar keinen Fall, den Kram an mehreren Stellen so ordentlich, wie es geht, zu beschriften.
Und ihr wisst, ich bin echt kein ordentlicher Mensch. Guckt euch das an.
Ich glaube, das ist Beweis genug, oder? Oder meint ihr, ich wäre sonderlich ordentlich?
Sowas halte ich das für äußerst sinnvoll.
So, okay, weiter.
Wäre das nicht das Beste, wenn man einfach die IP draufklebt?
Naja, was für eine IP klebst du drauf? Die IP des Management Interfaces,
oder die IP des Servers, was drauf ist?
Also ich wäre erstmal definitiv für die IP des Management Interfaces,
weil das das Wichtige ist, aber zusätzlich sollte man, finde ich,
wenn man eine direkte 1 zu 1-Zuordnung hat, nach Möglichkeit auch noch den Server draufkleben.
Klar, das macht Arbeit.
Und ja, das ist bei vielen Systemen eklig, aber wenn du später dann mal eine Datenbank hast mit einer Übersicht,
und das stimmt nicht, dann kannst du dir vieles anhand der Etiketten vielleicht noch rekonstruieren.
Weil wenn du bei uns, wir haben über 5000 Kisten da stehen,
du kannst dich nicht einfach mal der Reihe nach auf allen einloggen und gucken,
ah, wo ist denn jetzt der richtige Server drauf?
Und nicht nur 5000 Kisten, wir haben ja auch von diesen Kisten sind ja auch viele Container-Backends,
wo mehrere Sachendienste noch drauflaufen.
Wir haben eine ganz gute IT.
Inventarisierungs- und Dokumentationssoftware.
Aber das hilft dir nicht immer.
Das ist sowas, was in der Theorie das Problem löst,
aber in der Praxis bei der Änderung muss ja immer noch jemand ins Rechenzentrum gehen und die Hardware tauschen.
Und da kann immer irgendwann mal was vergessen.
Und selbst wenn du einen ordentlichen Update-Workflow hast und alle Leute sich dran halten,
nach einer Weile wird auf jeden Fall mal irgendwo an irgendeiner Stelle irgendeiner was vergessen.
Kennst du dich mit OVS? Das sagt mir jetzt nix.
Weiß ich, was ist OVS?
Damen- und Herrenbekleidung online.
OVS-Fashion. Ne, das meinst du wahrscheinlich nicht.
Open-Fashion. Ne, ne, hab ich noch nicht benutzt.
Aber ich bin auch kein ESX- und Virtualisierungs-Mensch.
Aber selbst wenn das Auto, du kannst dir einen Hardware-Tausch,
wenn du nicht gerade Roboter hast, die das tauschen,
selbst die können sich vielleicht mal vertun,
dann kannst du ja an der Stelle schlecht was automatisieren.
Selbst wenn du nicht gerade Roboter hast, die das tauschen,
selbst wenn du ein Dokusystem hast, was sich automatisiert alles von jedem ausliest,
das ist sinnvoll, dann können zumindest bei den Standard-Wartungsarbeiten keine Fehler passieren.
Aber wenn jemand ins Rechenzentrum geht und beispielsweise sagt,
hey, die Kiste braucht jetzt mal einen Hardware-Upgrade und tauscht das aus,
spätestens an der Stelle hilft dir eine reine Automatisierung nicht mehr.
An der Stelle muss dann umgeschrieben werden,
dass Server XY jetzt eben auf dieser Hardware läuft und nicht mehr auf dieser.
Und an der Stelle können Fehler passieren.
Gerade wenn du Leute hast, die am Tag, keine Ahnung,
100 Dinger rumfahren, auf einem Wagen tauschen, machen, tun,
spätestens, das kann einfach mal passieren.
Selbst wenn du es zu 99, überlegt es euch mal,
jemand hat eine Quote von 99% ordentlicher Arbeit,
ich würde mal sagen, das ist sogar schon relativ viel,
dann ist ein Server von 100 verkehrt.
Und das wird dir dann einfach auffallen, über kurz oder lang.
Das heißt, es ist ein System, wo du die Sachen erfasst,
und so ist alles eine super Geschichte,
aber es wird dir nicht, es wird nicht immer 100% korrekt sein.
Und früher oder später wirst du mal auf irgendeinen doofen Zufall treffen,
dass es nicht stimmt, und wenn du dann nichts anderes hast,
wo du noch irgendwie nachvollziehen kannst, was passiert ist,
keine Chance, ja.
Man kann sich da jetzt viele Fälle ausdenken,
wie man jetzt diesen Fall abfangen kann, jeden Fall, sonst wie.
Aber ihr könnt davon ausgehen, so ein System wird nie 100% sein.
Ich habe relativ keine Ahnung, was da passiert ist.
Ich schaue einfach in die E-Mails rein und gucke,
was seit gestern wieder reingekommen ist,
an neuen Tickets, an neuen Problemen.
Aber ich gucke dann auch ins Nagios rein.
Nagios, oh!
Die Oldschool-Variante, Nagios ist am Start.
Ich mag Nagios, Leute.
Ich mag Nagios.
Ich bin ja Nagios-Fan.
Es mag heute keiner mehr Nagios, ich weiß auch nicht, warum.
Nagios ist ein bisschen outdated, ja, okay.
Aber ich mag Nagios, aber das liegt einfach daran,
weil ich früher sehr viel Nagios gemacht habe.
Und irgendwie habe ich so ein, wie sagt man,
so ein weiches, sag mal, weiches Herz,
ein weiches Herz für Nagios.
Auch wenn ich heute wahrscheinlich keinen neuen Nagios installieren würde,
um irgendwas damit zu machen, aber ich mag Nagios.
Natürliche Geräte, wie beispielsweise Server oder auch Firewalls
und die Telefonanlage, aber auch die Videoanlage,
also die Videoüberwachung, die es hier auf dem Gelände gibt,
und für unterschiedliche Netzwerke, wie Hardware.
Und sobald eines der Geräte nicht korrekt funktioniert,
ist es Hacker-Typer, Sekunde, ist es Hacker-Typer?
Das ist Hacker-Typer.
Das ist Linux-Kernel-Code, glaube ich zumindest,
Linux-Kernel-Code über Hacker-Typer.
Wie macht der das eigentlich, mit einer Tastatur auf zwei Bildschirmen
was Unterschiedliches zu tippen?
Wie?
Was ist das für der ultrakrasse Hacker-Man, Alter?
Und sobald eines der Geräte nicht korrekt funktioniert,
also nicht erreichbar ist, zum Beispiel.
Der hat die linke Hälfte Tastatur für den linken Monitor
und die rechte Hälfte Tastatur für den rechten Monitor.
Excellent, excellent.
Und außerdem tippt er ganz schön wenige Tasten für viel Text.
Serious Hossi, danke schön für den Sub.
By the way, ich habe was ganz vergessen hier.
Toxie hat auch subscribed.
Dankeschön für die Subs, Leute.
Huge subscriptions.
Und Mr. MrFu2k hat auch subscribed.
Dankeschön, das habe ich gar nicht gesehen, schon ein paar Stunden her.
Kommen wir eine E-Mail und können dann auch in der Nagelsoberfläche selbst einsehen.
Ich habe mir übrigens überlegt, es gibt ja schon relativ günstige Möglichkeiten,
Stock-Videos, Stock-Footage zu kaufen.
Und ich habe mir überlegt, ob ich mir ein paar Stock-Videos kaufe,
weil ich mache ja in letzter Zeit viele Technik-Laber-Videos,
wo es halt auch mal 1-2 Minuten Downtime gibt
und die Leute immer abschalten oder gelangweilt sind,
wenn außerdem, dass ich erzähle, nichts passiert.
Ich habe mir schon überlegt, ob ich anstatt Gaming-Footage
dann einfach ab und zu mal so ein paar sinnlose Stock-Videos reinmache.
Welches Gerät gerade nicht funktioniert und was es für ein Problem hat.
Und entsprechend dann darauf reagieren.
Film dich doch selbst von hinten.
Ey, das ist mir zu dumm.
Neben meinen E-Mails checke ich dann auch noch das Ticketsystem.
Da bekommen wir auch regelmäßig...
Ich könnte mich selbst filmen.
Ich müsste mir irgendwie so eine Keksmaske oder so aufziehen.
Das ist eigentlich eine lustige Idee.
Das müsste ich mal...
Oder Blur ausblurren.
Aber das wirkt dann ziemlich weird.
Genau, das wirkt ziemlich weird.
Weird Champ.
Ich mache das besser, wie ich mir das schon mal gedacht habe.
Ich wollte mir auf Fiverr einen 3D-Avatar machen lassen.
Dann werde ich VTuber, Leute.
Ebenso gibt es auch immer wieder Neubestellungen, die da reinkommen.
Also wenn neue Geräte benötigt werden,
irgendwelche neuen Drucker fehlen oder ein neuer Mitarbeiter fängt an
und er benötigt.
Neue Konten oder einen neuen Arbeitsplatz.
Wenn ich mich morgens auf den aktuellen Stand gebracht habe...
Ja, da hätte ich keinen Bock drauf.
Da hätte ich keinen Bock drauf, ja.
Das Ticketsystem, da bekommen wir auch regelmäßig Tickets.
Also das ist ja normal.
Irgendwas bei den Anwendern nicht funktioniert.
Anwender-Support ist was, da hätte ich Peitsche.
Ist eigentlich laut genug.
... der Neubestellungen, die da reinkommen.
Also wenn neue Geräte benötigt werden,
irgendwelche neuen Drucker fehlen oder ein neuer Mitarbeiter fängt an
und er benötigt neue Konten oder einen neuen Arbeitsplatz.
Das ist okay.
Wenn ich mich morgens auf den aktuellen Stand gebracht habe
und geschaut habe, was ich alles schon zu tun habe,
es kommen natürlich auch immer wieder...
Oh, ich habe was vergessen, Leute.
Ich habe vergessen, Zeiterfassung zu machen letzte Woche.
Fällt mir gerade ein.
Was muss ich noch machen?
Ich hoffe, das geht nächste Woche noch für den vergangenen Monat.
... Sachen im Verlauf des Tages rein.
Ich beginne dann damit, die Sachen entweder chronologisch
oder nach der Priorität abzuarbeiten,
wenn da jetzt was Besonderes ist,
muss ich das natürlich zuerst bearbeiten.
Wenn da ein Problem ist mit dem Server oder dem Netzwerk,
muss ich da natürlich...
Zuerst dran.
Bevor ich an die Fehler bei den einzelnen Arbeitsplätzen drangehe.
Aus Datenschutzgründen darf ich euch natürlich hier nicht...
Das ist halt so die klassische Admin-Geschichte
in einem etwas kleineren Laden.
Dann hast du halt Admins, die kümmern sich um Netzwerk,
um Drucker, um lokale Probleme,
weil der Rechner nicht funktioniert,
ums Telefon, um die Webseite,
um den Windows-File-Server.
Die kümmern sich um alles.
Das ist so.
Das ist eigentlich ein bisschen...
Das ist halt aus der Mode gekommen in den letzten Jahren.
Das liegt aber auch daran, weil viele...
Es gibt immer mehr Gebiete
und die Gebiete werden auch immer komplexer.
Aber gerade in kleineren Läden
ist es halt nach wie vor so,
die haben halt kein Admin-Team aus 30 Leuten,
wo du dann jeder spezialisierte Gebiete hat.
Dann musst du die Basics eben als Admin bei allen machen.
Also das ist gar nicht so weit hergeholt.
Also das ist immer noch Standard,
bei vielen Läden.
Mr. Flöchen, danke für den Prime-Support.
Erstmal nach Indien outsourcen, genau.
Boah, da hätte ich...
Da hätte ich ja echt keinen Bock drauf.
Ganz ehrlich.
Jeder, was ihm Spaß macht, ganz klar.
Aber ich hätte keinen Bock drauf.
Dann hast du...
Wisst ihr, wisst ihr, wisst ihr, wisst ihr, was passiert?
Der baut den Monitor zusammen,
dann stellt er den Typ auf den Schreibtisch
und dann sagt er dem...
Aber der alte Monitor, der hatte schon bessere Farben.
Dann sagst du, nein, das kann nicht sein.
Der neue Monitor hat einen viel größeren Farbraum
und ist kalibriert.
Der hat nicht bessere...
Doch, doch.
Also das sieht ganz anders aus.
Der alte Monitor war schon besser.
So, und dann musst du dem Typ erstmal erklären,
dass er den alten Monitor nicht behalten kann.
Kann ich nicht einfach den alten Monitor behalten?
Außerdem steht er nicht richtig
und die Höhe stimmt auch nicht richtig.
Und der An- und Ausschalter ist an einer anderen Stelle.
Das funktioniert doch überhaupt nicht.
Ja, dann muss er sich erstmal eine halbe Stunde
mit den Leuten auseinandersetzen,
dass er ihnen jetzt den Monitor wegnehmen muss.
Und einen neuen hinstellen muss,
der eigentlich besser ist,
aber die Leute nicht wollen.
Das stört den Workflow, genau.
Labeldrucker.
Die hat Netzwerkprobleme.
Oldschool-Variante.
Labeldrucker drauf.
Inventar nochmal Gutes.
Das Problem, dass die in Macbook
nur sehr langsam auf unsere Netzwerk-Kasper zugreifen kann.
Ich tippe, ich tippe auf Layer-8-Problem.
Also unser Netzlaufwerk.
Und nicht, und nicht, by the way,
bevor das wieder jemand falsch versteht,
nicht, weil es eine Anwenderin ist.
Ja, bitteschön.
Ich tippe immer auf Layer-8-Problem.
Der Server läuft alles ganz normal
und geht alles schnell auf.
Also liegt da schon mal...
Geht gerade.
...eher an den Macbook
oder an eine Verbindung,
an eine Netzwerkverbindung.
Das Macbook der Kollegin
ist mit WLAN verbunden.
Ah.
Und es ist durchaus möglich,
dass es ein Problem
mit dem WLAN-Netzwerk gibt.
Oder eine gewisse Schwankung.
Wahrscheinlich.
Wahrscheinlich
sitzt sie an der denkbar ungünstigsten Stelle
mit WLAN an.
Erstmal darum gebeten, dass...
Erstmal zwischen fünf Gipswänden.
Gips ist übrigens für WLAN richtig kacke.
Ich weiß bis heute nicht, warum.
Weiß das jemand?
Warum?
Gipswände für WLAN so kacke.
Gipswände, da ist ja eigentlich fast nichts dran.
Ich meine Betonwände auch,
aber Gipswände hätte ich nie erwartet.
Ja.
Das funktioniert nur,
wenn du keine Port-Security hast.
Und wenn du keine Port-Security hast,
kann sich auch jeder dahergelaufene Typ
mit dem Notebook an ein Firmennetzwerk anstöpseln.
Das würde ich mir vielleicht nochmal überlegen.
Sie kann das von der Kollegin erstmal benutzen,
die gerade im Home-Office ist.
Und sie kann man dann testen,
ob das Problem auch nach dem Direktanschluss
an das Macbook,
beziehungsweise über einen Adapter an das Macbook
etwas bringt.
Und wenn ja, dann können wir auch bei ihr...
Liegt das bei Gips an den Metallständer weg, kann gut sein.
... das Problem auch über das Kabel auftritt.
Oh, beste Tri-Fi-Tasse, Leute.
Das ist eine gute Tasse, die gefällt mir.
Die ist nice.
Dann liegt das definitiv am Macbook.
Ja.
Wir müssen auch checken, was da nicht stimmt.
Aber erstmal wird sie das testen
und sich dann entsprechend vielleicht morgen
oder später dann zurückmelden.
Wie lange braucht ihr, um das zu testen?
Ihr musst den fucking Kabel einstecken.
Warum braucht ihr den Tag, um das...
Egal, egal.
Naja, acht Problem.
... Kollege aus dem Waren-Eingang gemeldet,
dass ein Telefon defekt ist, ein Mobilteil.
Wir nutzen hier solche Mobilteile.
Diese sind ziemlich robust und auch recht günstig.
Und reichen für solche Bedingungen völlig aus.
Das Problem, was er gemeldet hat, liegt daran,
dass dein Gerät nicht mehr hochfährt.
Also es lässt sich nicht mehr einschalten.
2021 booten auch DECT-Telefone.
... die ganze Zeit in der Dockingstation,
also in der Ladestation, stand.
Oder vielleicht auch WLAN.
Und es ist tatsächlich bei dem Telefon schon so,
dass ich nicht nur das Telefon mal ausgetauscht habe,
sondern auch den Akku mal ausgetauscht habe
und die Ladestation ausgetauscht habe.
Und er hat immer noch das Problem.
Das liegt wahrscheinlich daran,
dass das Telefon einfach schon zu alt ist.
Ich habe nämlich damals auch ein schon gebrauchtes Gerät gegeben.
Deswegen tausche ich diesmal alles aus.
Und ich habe auch schon ein neues Telefon für ihn eingerichtet gerade.
Und ich werde auch die Ladestation nochmal austauschen.
Und das Netzteil, also alle drei Komponenten werde ich gegen neue ersetzen.
Bei so einem etwas kleineren Laden hast du wirklich was zu tun.
Also da ist permanent irgendwas bei irgendeinem irgendwo kaputt.
Ich hätte da auch keinen Bock drauf,
aber ich kann mir vorstellen,
dass wenn man gerne mit...
Das kommt vielleicht in der IT selten vor,
aber wenn man doch...
Es mag doch Leute geben,
die gerne mit anderen...
Menschen interagieren,
dann ist das glaube ich ein super Job für so jemand.
Ich gebe ihm auch einen neuen Akku,
der wurde auch noch nie benutzt.
Also jetzt muss es einfach funktionieren.
Die Einrichtung unserer Telefone,
also in dem Fall der Tausch dieses Telefons,
geht über unsere Telefonanlage,
über die Software...
Ich kann mir schon vorstellen,
dass es nicht schlecht ist.
Ich hätte keinen Bock drauf,
aber es muss nicht schlecht sein.
... in dem Fall abmelden.
Wir müssen das einmal abmelden,
diese Rufnummer,
dass sie nicht mehr im System zu dem Telefon...
Unsere Telefonanlage läuft über...
Übrigens unter...
Hab ich mal gesehen.
Früher unter Suse und jetzt unter Ubuntu.
... gerade nicht funktioniert.
Und wenn die Nummer einmal frei ist,
dann können wir diese auf dem neuen Telefon registrieren.
Das nächste Problem,
was gemeldet wurde,
betrifft einen Zebradrucker.
Zebradrucker drucken...
Ein was?
Ach, der Hersteller ist Zebra.
So eine Art Label...
Zebradrucker, okay.
Einer dieser Drucker machte Probleme im Lager.
Und ich habe ihn untersucht.
Ich kann euch das leider nicht zeigen,
deswegen zeige ich euch das am Beispiel von diesem Drucker.
Der Drucker dort hatte das Problem,
dass er das Fahrband regelmäßig zerrissen hat
und das dann wieder neu eingelegt werden musste.
Ich beobachte das Problem dort schon seit einiger Zeit mit dem Drucker.
Also um zu sagen, der Zebradrucker suckt
in dem, was er machen soll.
Weil mir nicht ganz klar ist...
Nein, nein, nein.
Es ist nicht Asterisk.
Es ist irgendeine Siemens-Telefonanlage, glaube ich.
Keine Ahnung.
... dem steht, wieso er das manchmal zerreißt und manchmal nicht.
In diesem Fall ist es jedoch nicht weiter tragisch.
Denn bei dem Drucker kann man sich entscheiden,
ob man das Fahrband mitverwenden will.
Dann ist das Druckbild etwas besser.
Oder ob man auf das Fahrband verzichtet.
In dem Fall...
Ich weiß es nicht.
Keine Ahnung, was das ist.
Das funktioniert genauso.
Aber wie gesagt, das Druckbild kann...
Ich habe mit Telefonanlage nichts zu tun.
... so sieht das Fahrband aus.
Es ist jetzt noch eingepackt.
Es ist aber nichts Besonderes.
Es ist einfach nur ein Band um eine Rolle gewickelt.
Und dieses wird hier in den Drucker eingesetzt.
Und dann um die zweite Rolle hier gespannt.
Nach dem Einsetzen mit dem Drucker.
Nach dem Einsetzen wird das dann...
Ich mache ja immer in meinen Videos Witze darüber,
so nach dem Motto,
als Fachinformatiker kann man auch Druckerpatronen wechseln.
Das ist jetzt aber schon die Big-Brain-Variante von Druckerpatronen wechseln.
Druckerband wechseln.
Ich mache das jetzt nicht,
weil das jetzt nur ein Beispiel ist zum zeigen.
Und dann wird das Ganze so geklappt.
Ja, die epische Musik im Hintergrund.
Wobei, warum nicht?
... der Drucker auch direkt über Fahrband,
sofern das so eingestellt ist.
Im Verlaufe des Tages sind jetzt auch weitere Tätigkeiten angefallen.
Ein Kollege hat nämlich gemeldet,
dass sein iPhone nicht mehr funktioniert.
Dann verwendet ihr Siemens Unify TA.
Das kann ich dir sagen.
Siemens Unify TA.
Wenn man ein paar Telefone dazu sieht, passend.
Ja!
Sowas, sowas ähnliches haben wir.
Sowas.
Moment, Moment.
Mein Telefon auf der Arbeit sieht genau so aus,
nur dass es einen großen Bildschirm hat.
Sowas da.
Das.
Das da.
Das Telefon habe ich auf der Arbeit.
Nur in Grau.
Dunkel, dunkel, dunkel, fast schwarz im Grau.
Das da.
Das, das habe ich.
Das ist übrigens nicht gut, das Telefon.
Man denkt, das wäre ein Touchscreen, ist aber kein Touchscreen.
Ja.
Genau das, ja.
Das haben auch gefühlt alle, ja.
Ich habe schon bei einigen gesehen, ja.
Die sind nicht die einzigen.
So, was kommt denn jetzt als nächstes?
Also jetzt hat erstmal das Drucker,
jetzt hat erstmal das Drucker-Problem gefixt.
Okay.
Im Verlaufe des Tages sind jetzt auch weitere Tätigkeiten angefallen.
Ein Kollege hat nämlich gemeldet,
dass sein iPhone nicht mehr funktioniert.
Ja, wir haben einen Arbeitsplatz mit Telefon.
Aktuell geht auch alles über Teams.
Wenn die es jetzt noch schaffen,
dass ich über Teams angerufen werden kann
mit der Festnet-Nummer und telefonieren kann über Teams ins Festnetz
oder an Telefone, muss ja nicht Festnetz sein, Mobilfunk, wäre top.
Da es sich bei seinem iPhone schon um ein altes Modell handelt,
ein iPhone 6, kann ich das jetzt problemlos wechseln,
indem ich einfach ein neues über unseren Dienstleister bestelle.
Der Dienstleister bindet das Gerät dann bei sich in seinen...
Ich wurde übrigens auf der Arbeit mega angeschissen.
Die haben mir ein iPhone 11 geschickt zum Austausch für das iPhone XR
und ich habe halt das ausgepackt und habe mir gedacht,
okay, es ist genauso groß, es ist genauso schwer,
es sieht genauso aus, es ist wahrscheinlich nicht schneller.
Ich habe keinen Bock, das jetzt umzuziehen.
So.
Und da habe ich das neue iPhone einfach irgendwie 3 Monate
bei mir daheim liegen lassen und habe das alte weiterverwendet.
Und irgendjemand ruft mich dann vor, keine Ahnung, 3 Wochen oder so,
über Teams an und regt sich wahnsinnig auf,
warum ich das alte iPhone noch nicht zurückgeschickt habe.
Sie müssten jetzt extra Gebühren, Leasinggebühren,
beim Dienstleister bezahlen.
Weiß ich doch nicht.
Woher soll ich das wissen, Alter?
Und er meinte, ja, da kamen doch irgendwelche Benachrichtigungs-Mails
und sonst was.
Und ich habe mal nachgeguckt.
Ja, es kamen auch wirklich Benachrichtigungs-Mails.
Aber die Benachrichtigungs-Mails waren irgendwie an so einem komischen Verteiler,
wo anscheinend nur die Leute drin sind, die Verspätung haben.
Und ich filtere alles, was nicht direkt an mich geht per Mail,
mittlerweile weg.
Ich habe 3 Ordner.
Inbox, an mich und ans Team.
So.
Und alles, was nicht ans Team ist, an den Verteiler von meinem Team
und was nicht an mich ist, bleibt in Inbox.
Weil wir haben so extrem...
Wirklich.
Das könnt ihr euch vielleicht nicht vorstellen,
aber wir haben massiven Spam an Mails.
Also nicht Spam von Viagra und nigerianischem Prinz,
sondern internen Spam.
So nach dem Motto, Monitoring-System meldet ABC.
Von ABC habe ich noch nie was gehört.
Also wenn ich...
Das ist jetzt...
Ich übertreibe jetzt nicht, ne?
Wenn ich am Tag 500 Mails bekomme, dann ist das noch wenig.
Es ist so ein mega krasser Spam.
Von Monitoring-Meldungen, Nachrichten an alle.
Neue Version wurde deployed.
Komplett, wirklich komplett für den Arsch.
Und ich habe das schon seit ein paar Jahren so,
dass ich filtere, entweder die Mail geht an mich,
die Mail geht im CC an mich
und genau, Jira-Ticket-Updates und sowas.
Genau.
Oder aber es geht an meinen Team-Verteiler
und alles andere bleibt in der Inbox.
Dementsprechend habe ich die Warnungen,
weil die an einen fremden Verteiler gehen,
nicht gesehen, dass ich mein iPhone zurückschicken soll.
Zumindest war er echt stinkig.
War wirklich sauer, dass ich mein iPhone nicht zurückgeschickt habe.
Ich muss ihm dann sagen,
ja, ich mache jetzt gleich ein Backup und...
Ach ja, und ich habe ihm gesagt,
ich hätte es auch schon längst umgezogen,
wenn dieses Kopieren von iPhone zu iPhone funktioniert hätte.
Man kann ja normalerweise,
wenn man ein neues iPhone einrichtet, kann man sagen,
kopiere jetzt die Daten vom alten auf das neue iPhone
ohne iTunes und ohne Cloud.
Also direkt von iPhone zu iPhone.
Das haben die aber in ihrem Big-Brain-MDM abgeschaltet,
dass das geht.
Das ist natürlich bescheuert.
Die einfachste Migrationsmaßnahme-Möglichkeit
haben sie abgeschaltet.
So.
Und nachdem ich mir kein iCloud-Account privat holen wollte
mit erweitertem Speicher
für mein Firmen-iPhone,
weil der eigentliche iCloud-Account nicht reicht,
habe ich es halt über iTunes gebackupt
und restored auf dem neuen dann.
MdM ist einfach Mobile Device Management.
MdM ist einfach das Verwaltungssystem für Mobilgeräte.
Wenn das Gerät da einmal angebunden ist,
kann der Dienstleister dann das Gerät auch fernlöschen,
beispielsweise wenn es verloren geht oder gestohlen wird.
Aber der Hauptvorteil dieses MdMs liegt darin,
dass dann auf dem Gerät,
das kann mit iPhones gemacht werden,
aber auch mit...
Ja, Flo96 kommt da auch öfters vor.
...dass dann auf dem Gerät praktisch ein Container...
Aber du weißt doch,
das, was Flo96 sagt, ist eigentlich übrigens lustig,
kommt auch bei uns ab und zu mal vor.
Was aber witzig ist,
also er schreibt,
ach, bei euch, auch bei uns,
kann man die Mails mit
ich packe meinen Koffer vergleichen.
Kunde schickt ein Service,
Service wendet sich an jemand anderen,
dieser stellt eine Rückfrage an die Fertigung,
natürlich mit CC davor.
Irgendwann sind 20 Leute,
bis irgendjemand auffällt,
der Kunde ist noch im Verteil drin.
Ja, so ähnliche Sachen haben wir auch,
wobei es bei uns selten wirklich komplett externe Leute sind,
aber sowas haben wir auch.
Aber Dienstleister und so sind da teilweise immer drin,
auch mit Kommunikation,
die sie nicht bekommen wollen.
Und was die Lösung,
die Big-Brain-Lösung dazu ist jetzt,
dass es einen Standard-Disclaimer gibt in der Signatur,
wo drin steht,
dass wenn man fälschlicherweise eine Mail bekommt,
dass man die ignorieren soll, so sinngemäß.
Das bringt es natürlich, ne?
Das ist natürlich way too smart.
So nach dem Motto,
wir verkacken es,
aber wenn ihr uns erwischt beim Verkacken,
dann, ja,
dann darfst du es nicht angucken.
So Mails habt ihr bestimmt auch schon bekommen.
Wenn diese Mail fälschlich an sie zugestellt wurde,
dann ignorieren sie das bitte und sowas.
Naja.
Für das Business, also...
Oh, iPhone.
WLAN-Leak, Leute.
WLAN-Leak.
Bluetooth-Leak.
Beoplayer 1, Leak.
Für das Business,
also es gibt dann praktisch zwei verschiedene Bereiche,
für die Privatnutzung
und für das Business.
Und die ganzen Apps und die Daten,
die im geschäftlichen Container dann abgelegt werden
und installiert werden,
haben dann keinen Zugriff auf den privaten Bereich auf dem Gerät.
Ja, so haben wir das auch.
So kann dann sichergestellt werden,
dass keine Geschäftsdaten auf privatem Wege
beispielsweise das Gerät verlassen.
Was als nächstes ansteht, sind zwei Rechner,
die geliefert wurden.
Ich muss diese PCs einrichten für uns.
Diese Geräte sind...
Yes, Hackerman, Hackerman-Time.
Also da ist einfach...
Äh.
... für uns.
Diese Geräte sind bereits vorinstalliert mit Windows.
Ah.
Also da ist einfach Windows 10 Professional drauf.
Und ich...
Ja gut, ist aber auch klar auf dem Desktop.
... unsere Einstellungen.
Ein Teil unserer Einstellungen kommt direkt...
Was denn auch sonst?
... Server, aber...
Winux vielleicht oder...
oder Limux oder...
Wie hieß das aus München nochmal?
... unserem Domain-Controller.
Da sind nämlich Group Policies hinterlegt,
also Gruppenrichtlinien,
die direkt auf die Geräte ausgerollt werden.
Aber das meiste muss ich direkt auf dem Gerät einmal installieren.
Wir haben zwar auch
eine Software-Verteilung,
die ist aber gerade noch nicht funktionsfähig.
Der Klassiker!
Wir haben eigentlich eine Software-Verteilung,
die geht aber eigentlich nicht richtig.
Ja.
Damit kann sich, glaube ich, jeder ganz gut identifizieren.
Der Felix, bei uns auf der Arbeit,
mit dem habe ich ja schon mal zu Gamescom Video gemacht,
der hat vor, weiß ich nicht, drei Wochen oder so,
hat er gesagt, er hätte gerne auf seinem Windows-Notebook
oder auf seiner Windows-VM, ich weiß es gar nicht genau,
zumindest auf einem offiziellen, ähm,
von unseren Windows-Notebooks,
von unseren Windows-Leuten gemanagten Client-System,
hätte er gerne das neue Windows-Terminal.
Die machen seit drei Wochen oder über drei Wochen damit schon rum.
Also es funktioniert bei uns auch richtig.
Und was wir, Leute, wo ich wirklich schon,
wo ich mal wirklich gespannt bei uns drauf bin,
ich soll ja demnächst auch noch ein neues Notebook bekommen,
ich habe ja aktuell auf der Arbeit nur zwei Notebooks liegen,
ein altes Linux-Gerät, ein neues Linux-Gerät,
und ich soll jetzt noch ein Windows-Gerät bekommen.
Ich soll auch ein Windows-Gerät bekommen,
dass ich quasi immer die offiziellen Firmensachen verwenden kann,
so wenn es, wenn es drauf ankommt.
Und da, da wird es noch lustig,
ich werde da jetzt einen Antrag machen,
dass die mir Rider drauf installieren,
weil ich relativ viele auch auf der Arbeit .NET-Programme habe,
die ich natürlich weiterentwickeln will.
Und selbstverständlich mache ich das natürlich dann
von der offiziellen Windows-Workstation aus, ja.
Wie käme ich, wie käme ich auf eine andere Idee?
Ähm, da mache ich jetzt mal einen Antrag auf
installiert mir mal Rider.
Und das wird, das wird, das wird witzig.
Da, das, das, da weiß ich jetzt schon,
das wird sie, wird sie fertig machen.
Also, da müssen sie erst mal gucken,
wo bekommen sie das her?
Wie packagen sie das Ganze jetzt?
Und dann haben sie es installiert,
und ich wette, nach dem Installieren fällt ihnen auf,
fuck, wir müssen ja eine Lizenz für kaufen.
Und wir haben keine Lizenz dafür.
Da, da bin ich mal gespannt.
Das dauert bestimmt ein halbes Jahr,
bis ich Rider auf meinem Notebook habe.
... also ein neues Master-Image drauf kopieren,
dann kann ich das auch direkt über das Master-Image,
installieren, was dann viel schneller geht.
Aber da ich noch keine Zeit hatte,
das Image für die Software-Verteilung zu erstellen,
muss ich die Geräte...
Das ist, das ist immer, eins habe ich,
ich muss immer laufen,
das habe ich schon gelernt,
also das darf man ja, das darf man nicht sagen.
Keine, die, die keine Zeit ausrede,
da trägt, das trägert manche Leute.
Du musst, du musst sagen, zumindest,
zumindest bei uns,
du musst eher den, den Business-Move machen,
da sind wir gerade dran.
Da sind wir gerade dran, es geht voran,
es gibt noch ein paar technische Hürden,
aber wir sind gerade daran, die zu beheben.
Das ist so die diplomatische Antwort zu,
ich habe noch keine Zeit oder noch keinen Bock.
Man muss immer sagen, da sind wir dran,
das ist aber gar nicht so einfach,
aber wir, wir arbeiten mit Hochdruck daran,
die technischen Hürden zu beheben.
So, das ist viel besser.
Das nehme ich mit, ist auch sehr beliebt.
Oder genau, es wurde runter priorisiert,
ist auch gut,
aber da musst du dich noch rumstreiten.
Das umsetzen wir uns,
das ist so lächerlich,
das ist schon in der Lage,
das ist jetzt eine Art Wunde.
Das ist die Wunder,
wie wir uns Wunder machen,
aber wir haben den Weg nach oben gemacht.
Wir müssen vielleicht schon darauf achten,
wie wir das jetzt machen landen,
wie wir das jetzt machen,
wie wir das jetzt machen.
Also, wir müssen uns da gut rein roomstrecken.
Das ist ja verblieben,
das ist ja verblieben,
wahrscheinlich der Grund,
warum wir uns nicht mehr wohl machen.
Aber wir müssen erst mal
nicht konsolidieren
und wir müssen nochmal
die Gewalt haben,
die die Leute haben.
Wir müssen das nicht machen.
Deswegen,
das ist der Grund,
warum wir uns nicht mehr wohl machen,
die sind cool die sind cool aber durchaus leistungsstark
und wir benutzen sie hier durchaus gerne wir benutzen auch noch die kleineren
desktop pc also ich habe sie noch nie live selbst verwendet aber ich kenne die
dinger die die finde ich cool die kann ich auch mal eben zeigen das sind die
kleineren pc ist die mich auch noch verwenden das ist jetzt ein haben gehen
das so dass 400 diese geräte haben wir das hallo lass es mal auf dass es auf
bleibt und für normale office jetzt geht es mal die im büro anfallen diese
pc besitzen auch zwei das report am schluss sehen wie lange es noch geht
noch zwei monitor digital anschließen kann
es gibt noch einen vg anschluss programmierst du auf der arbeit eher
tooling ja also jemand noch ein office gerät braucht das sind auf jeden fall
pc ist die ich empfehlen kann wir haben viele sachen einsatz und die erfreuen
sich auch einer großen beliebtheit also das letzte das letzte wo ich am freitag
dann gebastelt habe ist folgendes also ja es ist
eher tooling das ist das was wir übrigens auch schon mal in einem stream
ausprobiert haben ob man das nicht in der asia function packen kann
ich habe was programmiert was ich okay da muss ich ein bisschen ausholen das
habe ich auch schon mal erzählt wir haben den spam anbieter wir haben ein
anbieter der macht spam filtering für uns aber wir filtern nicht nur eingehende
mails auf spam wir filtern auch ausgehende mails auf spam weil wir haben
einen e-mail service für den außendienst und manchmal verschickt der außendienst
halt spam das ist schlecht für unsere mails
reputation wenn wir es beim verschicken so und da gibt es jetzt eine aufgabe die
unser support hat und zwar man muss dreimal am tag in das web interface gehen
von dem anti von dem spam filter anbieter ins web interface dort die
mails anklicken und dann freigeben das ist eine ziemlich lästige nervige
nervige aufgabe und da habe ich jetzt was programmiert das ist auch mehr oder
weniger als auf meinem ist ursprünglich mal gewachsen dass man so was machen
kann dass der einen ferngesteuerten chromium nimmt per puppetier das da das
da das ist kann man chrome fern steuern oder was heißt man kann chrome
automatisieren darüber der macht quasi einen chrome auf headless auf der
kommando also das geht ohne ohne grafische ausgabe warum mahnt ihr die
mitarbeiter nicht ab moment es geht nicht um mit es geht um den außendienst
der außendienst ist die die fett stonks machen die werden nicht abgemahnt wäre ja blöd
die verdienen ja dieses geld warum sollst du die ab machen damit kann man
einen browser fern steuern bzw automatisieren ich habe es jetzt so
gebaut dass ich dieser browser quasi im hintergrund in chrome aufmacht und dann
automatisiert sich beim spam provider einloggt beim spam provider die e-mails
freigibt es ist ein bisschen was wie selenium ja im endeffekt so was in der
richtung und das ganze aber mit zwei faktor authentifizierung das war ein
bisschen komplizierter automatisiert zwei faktor authentifizierung zu machen und
wenn das ganze dann durch ist dann suchte sich das aktuellste ticket raus
für diese spam freigeben schreibt dort ein report rein und macht das ticket zu
wenn es dennoch offen ist also das ist wirklich ein tool was gerade vom support
die arbeit finde ich schon deutlich erleichtert ja das ist das letzte was
gerade gebastelt habe am freitag oder weiter daran gebastelt habe weil es
funktioniert schon eine weile und das ticket schließen ist aber grad weil sich
ticket status geändert hat
ja also so sachen wenn ich sachen programmieren programmiert er so tool
geschichten und der nächste der nächste trick die
nächste sache wird sein dass ich das auf der arbeit mal versuche umzuziehen
dieses programm in der asia function da bin ich mal gespannt ob das funktioniert
weil wir sind ja mittlerweile richtig cloud cloud native cloud cloud first big
brain cloud time da muss muss das sein ist das der sohn von kinder hat ein
bisschen ähnlichkeit
aber die dinge sind wirklich cool dass nicht die dier davor gezeigt hat
da sind intel nux pc die sind also wirklich sehr klein und auch
vergleichsweise leistungsschwacher aber es trotzdem noch nicht dafür das ganze
office zeug und dieses gerät hier auch an die drei prozessor der siebten
generation was zu normalen office arbeiten grundsätzlich auch reichen
würde aber tatsächlich sind diese ente lux nicht besonders schnell und auch
wenig anschluss stark ja das stimmt pc express kannst du ja dann kannst du auch
im paket
gibt es schon mal gar nicht mehr bietet das gerät auch nicht falls ihr euch fragen solltet ob ich
hier in der firma alleine bin nun ist es so dass meine kollegen aktuell home office machen wir
wechseln uns da gegenseitig ab die haben die haben trotz automatisierung noch zu wenig support leuten
leute die kriegen ihre schichten schon gar nicht mit mindestens zwei leuten besetzt aktuell als
die suchen immer noch händeringend leute die aufgaben die fortgemacht wir sind ja 24 7 da
unser support hauptsächlich und meine kollegen kümmern sich dann um die aufgaben die auch der
mod bewältigt werden können die sie dann von zu hause mit ihren vier notebook erledigen können
bevor ich jetzt mit weiteren aufgaben fortfahren werde ich erstmal den monitor ausliefern und ja
monitor ausliefern erst mal mit dem typ diskutieren der kann neuen monitor haben
will dann natürlich mal los nun er hat sich der arbeitstag dem ende und es gab noch viele
anfragen und tickets die kann ich euch leider aber so nicht zeigen weil ich hier einfach in
den räumlichkeiten nicht
filmen darf aber ich kann euch im groben dennoch erzählen was es für anfragen gab und was es für
probleme noch gab die zu lösen waren zum einen musste ich für einen neuen kollegen der bald
hier eingestellt wird und bald hier beginnt ein neues nein ich poste ich poste die chat an die
stellanzeige hier nicht im chat mache ich einfach bei amazon und suche dann nach einem notebook mit
einem guten leistungsverhältnis ok das finde ich interessant bei uns ist es eigentlich so dass die
23 verschiedene notebook
typen haben so letzte generation aktuelle generation und jetzt was demnächst eingeführt wird das halt
alle nach möglichkeiten mehr oder weniger die gleiche art wir haben es ist oftmals nicht
praktikabel für mehrere hundert ich weiß gar nicht wie viel es sind ja schon verdammt viele leute bei
uns den alle exakt das gleiche notebook zur verfügung zu stellen das kriegen sie nicht hin
wir haben uns jetzt auch lenovo notebooks aber sagen wir so bei uns ist halt die lobo notebooks
dann jetzt die die ganz neue und die letzte generation so das wird dann das wird bei uns so
alle zwei drei jahre wird das oder ja alle drei jahre wird das mal getauscht und leider braucht
man beim bei lenovo dann öfters auch neue docking stations und sowas was ein bisschen bisschen
ätzend ist ja dell hatten wir auch mal wir haben auch mal fujitsu siemens probiert damals aber
hauptsächlich haben wir lenovo und gerade durch die knappheit aktuell mit der lieferung haben die
echt probleme gerade allen aktuelle notebook neue notebooks bereitzustellen
in dieser anforderung habe ich hier mein notebook für ihn ausgesucht nämlich das
konzept 3 das habe ich auch für die anderen kollegen in der IT gekauft und das erfreut
sich auch großer beliebtheit meine oma meine oma meine oma hat immer gesagt archer zu acer
das war das sein drucker jedes mal also könnt ihr euch vorstellen wie lange das her ist meine
oma ist meine oma gestorben 2003 oder so die hat immer gesagt das ist ein drucker jedes mal
also könnt ihr euch schon vorstellen wie lange das her ist meine oma ist meine oma gestorben 2003 oder so die hat immer gesagt das ist ein drucker jedes mal
archer zu acer notebooks
der neustart des computers wieder verschwindet und der drucker den er benutzt jedes mal neu einbinden muss
das liegt ganz einfach daran weil unsere drucker über gruppenrichtlinien verteilt werden die direkt
eben vom active directory kommen um das problem zu lösen musste ich den kollegen im active directory in den richtigen raum setzen
und ich musste zusätzlich auch den drucker ihm entsprechend auch als drucker zuweisen
also das drucker konfigurierung gemacht das wird mir persönlich nicht gefallen
standard drucker hinterlegen was wir im verlaufe des tages sowieso immer machen
müssen
what the fuck was wir was wir im verlaufe des tages sowieso immer machen
müssen das ist zum einen das backup wir haben einen backup da braucht backup
beziehungsweise also backup ist overrated also das ist wie das ist wie
source code dokumentation guter source code muss nicht dokumentiert werden ja
und wenn alles sicher ist braucht man auch kein backup sind wir uns einig
hoffe ich aber neben sicherung die auf festplatten laufen also auf server
festplatten haben wir auch sicherung die auf bänder laufen die bänder mögen etwas
altmodisch sein dennoch sind diese leistungsfähig das stimmt so ein band
hat haben wir auch haben wir auch über acht terabyte speicherplatz was wir hier
verwenden und auch so ein band wird die gesamte sich einfach enterprise ssds
kaufen die gehen nicht kaputt wir haben das sind einige dutzend
nein nein nein ernsthaft backup ist eine wichtige geschichte dann jeden abend
drauf kopiert und diese sicherung da geht es ja auch um viel geld ein jahr
physisch die sind halt so aufgeteilt dass wir monats
bänder haben wochen bänder und tagesbänder und das wollen wir dann ein
jahr bewegungsweise können wir dann auch ältere stände wiederherstellen und auch
da wieder finden wenn die anwalt karantäne was wir mehrmals im tag
internen adressen sondern wirklich von externen adressen diese e-mails landen
automatisch in der ok spam spam da wird noch hacker man am rack gemacht jetzt
will ich erstmal alles selber machen so kann also der arbeitstag eines
fachinformatikers für systemintegration ablaufen oder eines
technologischen periode was ist das hier jetzt nicht richtig ist es ein
regal die aufgenommen sind die auch in den anwalt das heißt wer das
prämium nochmal sprich mit wem das sind jetzt docker oder hatte das bei sich
aufgenommen also in der in der firma das kann durchaus das kann durchaus dort
super wie geleckt aussehen, aber
das ist durchaus brauchbar verkabelt.
Also da habe ich schon Schlimmeres gesehen.
...administratus oder System
Engineers, da gibt es ganz unterschiedliche Bezeichnungen
für diese Jobs.
Admingrill.
Adminnen.
Huge.
Oder man ist Netzwerktechniker und beschäftigt sich ohnehin
nicht mit dem Tagesgeschäft in der Form,
sondern stattdessen mit Firewalls
und Switchen.
Linksus haben wir nicht, aber
kann ich mir gut vorstellen,
also wenn man sich da wirklich um alles kümmern muss,
dann auch um Switche und Netzwerksachen.
Ich hoffe, das Video hat euch gefallen
und ihr konntet da was für euch mitnehmen.
Insbesondere, falls ihr wirklich eine
Ausbildung macht gerade.
Das ist halt auch wiederum überhaupt nicht repräsentativ.
Es gibt nichts, wo man so
sagen kann, hey, das ist die Sache,
die man als Fachinformatiker Systemintegration
macht. Linksus, nee, Netgear
war die Billigschiene von Cisco, oder?
Oder bring ich es jetzt durcheinander, oder? Linksus?
Nee. Ach, kein Schimmer mehr.
Es ist halt genauso
wenig repräsentativ, was ich
in meinen Videos sage.
Also es gibt so viele
unterschiedliche Themengebiete und so
viele unterschiedliche Einsatzgebiete,
wo man eben als
IT-Mensch hin kann.
Das sind alles nur Eindrücke aus einzelnen
losgelösten Sachen. Bei meinen
Videos ist es ja auch nicht anders.
Hat das Cisco?
Ist es nicht sogar Linksus bei Cisco früher?
Oder war das Netgear?
Kann man das immer nicht merken?
Net, Net, Net,
Netgear.
Nee, das war Linksus.
Ja, ja.
Exzellent. Nee, nee, es war Linksus.
Was sagst du zur Ausbildung versus Studium?
Ist halt komplett unterschiedlicher
Fokus, ja. Also wenn du
aus dem Studium kommst, heißt das nicht, dass du direkt
anfangen kannst
und irgendwas zu arbeiten.
Und dann, äh, Industrie bezogen,
ja, das,
das ist nach einer Ausbildung anders.
Dafür lernst du halt in einem Studium
deutlich mehr Hintergründe
und theoretische Sachen.
Also, nach einem Studium kannst du
beweisen, äh, dass
der, dass die
Laufzeit von
einer sortierten Liste
immer
Was ist das denn eigentlich aus dem Kopf?
Log N?
Weiß ich doch nicht mehr. Kein Schimmer.
Äh, oder so ist.
Da weißt du, was Sache ist.
Und bei einer Ausbildung hast du keine Ahnung davon,
aber du weißt beispielsweise,
wie du Linux-Kisten administrierst.
Es ist...
ziemlich unterschiedlich.
Kann man so gar nicht sagen.
Wie findest du New World?
Ähm...
Gut, jetzt die Beta ist ja fast vorbei. Also, ich hab ein Video
dazu gemacht übrigens. Ich weiß nicht, ob du das schon gesehen hast.
Äh, sag ich ja ein bisschen.
Hast du das Video schon gesehen?
Da sag ich ein bisschen was zu. Im Prinzip seh ich das immer noch so.
New World fühlt sich ein bisschen...
fühlt sich ein bisschen...
identitätslos an.
Hast du was mit BSD gemacht? Ja.
Mit FreeNAS
und mit, äh, OpenSense.
Das ist was, wo ja auch BSD drunter ist.
Aber so
wirklich viel mit BSD
hab ich noch nicht gemacht.
Fange erst neu bei einem Provider die Ausbildung zum
fiesen Katzenhunderschwein... Ich hab doch so viele
Videos, wo ich irgendwelche, äh,
Schwenke erzähle.
Was willst denn da jetzt wissen?
Ich mein, ich hab bestimmt schon
fünf Videos drüber gemacht, wo ich Dinge aus der Ausbildung
erzählt hab.
Was ist dieses Half-Life Programm?
Das ist ne Terminal. Ja.
Nice. So, mal kurz gucken, dass
ich nicht irgendwelche Chat-Messages
hier übersehen hab.
Man verkauft immer nur Backup, aber niemals
Restore. Ja, aber Backup
ohne Restore zu testen ist auch
kein richtiges Backup. Also
eigentlich muss man schon regelmäßig testen, ob's funktioniert.
Sonst hast du vielleicht Scheiße gebaut
und Backup ist gar nicht alles, was du brauchst und merkst
das nicht. Oder der Restore
funktioniert nicht. So sieht's
aus.
Am besten sind auch, wenn man viele Variablen
Namen mit einem Buchstabe nimmt
oder Temp oder Blup oder
Count oder so. Ist auch immer super
zum Selbstdokumentieren.
Keine Ahnung. Mich würd's
nicht stören. Ich trink aber auch keinen Kaffee.
Das würd mich, also
mich würd das nicht stören.
Es gibt Arbeitgeber, die haben
Policy, dass du keine eigenen Elektronik
Geräte mitbringen darfst.
Also du darfst ja auch keine eigene Mikrowelle
mitbringen oder so.
Tja, musst du gucken.
Ja, korrekt.
Kollege hat mir letztens
erzählt, er verwendet bei sich im Wohnzimmer als
Mediacenter-PC
nen alten Rechner, den er von der Arbeit mitgenommen hat.
Und da hab ich gesagt, Moment, von...
Also, den durfte man mitnehmen. Ja, den hat er nicht
geklaut. Den durfte man mitnehmen, weil die
weggeschmissen wurden. Da hab ich gesagt, aber das war
doch 2009
oder so. Was ist denn das?
Ja, ich weiß nicht. Das geht immer noch gut.
Das ist irgendein Pentium 4 oder sowas.
Damit kriegst du wahrscheinlich noch nicht mal
1080p ordentlich abgespielt.
Aber gut, jeder, jeder...
Jeder wie er meint.
Okay.
Also, next.
I build an Adventure-Background for my cats.
Okay.
White-Pepo-Happy-Video.
Vermute ich jetzt mal.
White-Pepo-Happy-Time.
Jawoll.
Hi life.
Kättke.
...
Ja. Kommt auf die Katz auf.
Kommt, kommt, die Katz auf...
Also Chico hat Angst vorm Freien.
Das, wo ich mir mehr Gedanken drüber machen würde, ist eine Straße, ehrlich gesagt.
Dass irgendjemand meine Katze klaut, vergiftet oder sonst was, gehe ich mal nicht.
Vor Autos hätte ich mehr Bedenken.
Ach, Quatsch.
Also Katzen, die Vögel fangen, dass Katzen viele Vögel fangen,
dass Katzen viele Vögel fangen, dass Katzen viele Vögel fangen,
dass das der Population was macht, halte ich für ein Gerücht.
Die Vögel sind doch auch nicht doof.
Ja, wenn die Vögel an einem Ort sitzen, wo sie laufend gefangen werden, dann gehen sie woanders hin.
Sie sind doch nicht bescheuert.
Was finde ich?
Das ist ein großer Weg in eine Entschlussung, ähnlich wie ein Hühnchenrennen.
Das bedeutet, dass die Katzen ein bisschen frische Luft bekommen, während ich Frieden habe,
wissend, dass sie beide glücklich und sicher sind.
Nun, mein Garten ist genau der Größe eines Postage-Stamps,
also haben wir nicht viel Raum, mit dem wir arbeiten.
Und seit ich nur dieses Haus rentiere, bin ich nicht ermöglicht,
in es Bätten zu dringen, wie man es normalerweise bauen würde,
so etwas wie das.
Stattdessen muss es völlig freestandig sein,
was Dinge um eine Million Mal schwieriger macht.
Mein Arbeitsumfang ist es, sechs Posten auf dem Boden zu spenden,
um strukturelle Unterstützung zu bieten.
Danach werde ich ein Holzbau bauen,
mit einem dünnen Bildschirm über die Vorderseite,
mit einer großen Tür, und dann werde ich...
Wie soll ich das denn bei mir...
Wo soll ich das denn...
Das wird bei mir im Leben nicht funktionieren.
Dann wäre die Terrasse komplett voll.
Könnte ich nicht mehr...
Könnte ich selbst nicht mehr drüberlaufen.
Komm nicht mehr ins Haus.
... ein Rufestand auf dem Boden bauen.
Max ist jetzt Reaction-Streamer geworden.
Klar.
Kein Druck, Content.
Leichtes Geld, leichtes Leben.
So muss das sein.
... mit Mesh, um die Entschlussung zu beenden.
Also, hier ist ein cooles Bildmontage.
Beton...
B-B-Betonge...
... hier.
Katscham!
... die Vorderseite ist jetzt auf dem Boden gebaut.
In nur 25 Sekunden ist es fertig.
Ich sollte alles mit einem Montage machen.
Das würde überhaupt nicht funktionieren.
Das würde überhaupt nicht klappen.
Ich habe es irgendwie nicht aufgemischt.
Mit der grundlegenden Struktur,
die in Caproof beendet wurde,
dachte ich, es wäre Zeit,
Ralf und Bella ihre ersten Lungenfüße
mit frischem Wasser in fast einem Jahr zu machen.
Ich werde in einem Moment
alle coolen Steigerungen hinzufügen.
Aber für den Moment will ich sie einfach
einfach draußen holen.
Und mit dem Rauschen in das Unbekannte
war Bella weg.
Und alle Reservationen, die sie hatte, sind weg.
Bravely exploring her new garden.
Da traut sich Chico vielleicht auch raus.
Immediately she started scratching on the fence posts.
Natürlich.
Was sie da um den Hals hat.
Keine Ahnung.
Aber es gibt manche Katzen,
die beruhigt das,
wenn sie von Sachen umgeben sind, die sie kennen.
Vielleicht hat die das freiwillig an.
Keine Ahnung.
Once Ralf realized what was happening,
he came to watch from the doorstep.
It took him just under a minute
to venture outside,
which admittedly is a lot less than I thought it would.
His senses were in overdrive
as he sniffed everything
and his ears and body reacted to every sound.
Peppo happy Musik hier.
He kept going back inside briefly,
just to feel safe before coming out again.
And before long he was exploring
every inch of his new patio.
And I mean every inch.
I think it's time we build him something proper.
Also das muss wirklich dicht sein.
Katzen sind auch wunderbar drin,
sich durch irgendwas durchzudrücken.
But then it rained nonstop for over a week.
Ralf wasn't brave enough to even step a paw outside.
And I don't blame him.
The British weather can be pretty unpleasant.
So once it eventually stopped raining,
which yes, does occasionally happen,
my first job was to add some shelter.
I nailed these corrugated roof sheets in
with these strange giant nails,
which oddly enough are supposed to be hammered in at the peaks,
not the troughs as you might expect.
I only covered one corner,
as I didn't want to make it too dark.
But hopefully it should give some protection
against the British weather.
Now it was time to build the adventure playground.
The plan is to cement another post in the ground in the middle,
to attach a circular platform.
It will be connected to a larger platform in the corner,
with a bridge across to a high-up platform in the other corner.
It will all be accessible using a climbing wall on the right.
There will also be three platforms on this left wall,
staggered to make it easy for Ralf and Bella to climb between them.
I got started with the cement straight away,
and then they suddenly failed at their pencil and string trick
to draw a perfect circle.
I ended up printing one out
and cutting around that instead.
Next I cut the highest part of it.
So perfect is the circle
now not anymore after he cut it out.
Next I cut the highest part of it.
No, you don't need permission for that.
So a few strips and...
I would do it a little differently
if I were to build something like that.
I would probably use our front roof
as a base,
and put two or three strips over it.
There is something on the other side
where you can put it on.
And then I would probably take
some kind of net,
which I can just put over it
and then I would fix it on both sides.
Something like that.
I probably wouldn't build such a wooden construction.
I cut the highest platform to size
and screwed it into place using brackets.
Listen to the noise this screwdriver makes
when it's struggling.
Yeah, something like that.
Yeah, something like that
you do with a smart screwdriver.
Yeah, okay, there are...
I admit, there are
funnier things.
More LEDs.
I cut my thumb about 432 times.
But when they were done, they looked marvelous.
And I was even more excited
to see them at night.
But back to the adventure playground.
I built another shelf on the left
and since it was getting late,
decided to varnish what I'd done so far
and call it a day.
The next morning, I screwed two planks of wood together
using a...
On the back to make the climbing wall,
I attached these super colorful climbing grips
and then mounted it in place
using hinges to get the angle right.
I attached an extra beam of wood underneath for support
since it's pretty heavy.
Next, I added a small walkway
between this and the second platform
and then a large walkway between the two back platforms.
Everything was really starting to take shape now.
Now I actually want to put another shelf
between these two for this.
I realize it's highly unlikely
the cats will ever see it.
So was hab ich auch mal probiert,
so was zum Hängen an der Heizung.
Das hat man an der Fensterbank dran gemacht.
Das war dann an der...
Also zwischen Fensterbank und Heizung.
Das war der zu...
zu MonkaS, das Teil.
Chico ist eh extrem misstrauisch gegenüber allem.
Die braucht teilweise
ein halbes Jahr, bis sie dann...
Ich hab der mal so einen Tunnel gekauft,
so einen Tunnel, der raschelt, ja.
Den hat die erst ein halbes Jahr mit dem Arsch nicht angeguckt.
Und heute, jedes Mal, wenn ich abends
ins Bett gehe,
setzt die sich hinter den Tunnel
dann, also...
Ne, ich gehe ins Bad, die merkt das ja schon,
wenn ich abends ins Bad gehe.
Ich gehe abends ins Bad, gehe nochmal aufs Klo, putz Zähne
und wenn ich dann rüberlaufe, am Wohnzimmer vorbei,
sitzt die in ihrem Tunnel
und kommt raus geflitzt und fängt mich dann.
Das heißt also nach dem Motto, jetzt mach nochmal ein bisschen Action mit mir.
How cool is this?
I cannot wait for Ralph & Bella to never use it.
And then I put a shelf directly underneath.
Und ihr kennt meinen Arm,
die fängt mich öfters.
Finally, I decided the climbing wall
was probably a bit too steep.
So I adjusted the angle and added a final platform
to encourage the cats onto it.
Meine Katz liegt gern auf dem Kühlschrank.
Ich hab da auch so ein Brett hochgelegt.
Also von...
Ich hab einen Kühlschrank, daneben steht
der Wäschetrockner
und da vorne ein Stuhl.
Also sie hüpft auf den Stuhl, auf den Wäschetrockner.
Ich hab da vom Wäschetrockner auf den Kühlschrank
auch sowas hochgebaut.
Das juckt die überhaupt nicht, die springt immer.
The catio was entirely finished.
Tum Tum Tum Tum Tum Tum
Ralph was first up,
bravely negotiating the climbing wall
and heading straight to the highest point.
Da wird jetzt erstmal ausgeruht oben.
Erstmal hingelegt.
Genau, das war klar.
Erstmal hingelegt und geguckt.
...and stayed there until he fell asleep.
Eventually, he made his way back down the wall
using the grips like I hoped he would.
Die Katz ist auch gut dabei.
Vielleicht liegt's aber auch am Fell.
...tried her best to avoid the grips.
She's been a bit unwell lately.
It's nothing at all to worry about,
but she didn't fancy staying outside for too long
before once again doing her absolute best
not to use the climbing grips
and heading back inside.
Die denkt sich jetzt, was hat denn der da für'n
Scheiß gebaut, das kann man doch nicht mal richtig
langlaufen. Wie unfähig
kann man sein, so ne Kacke zu bauen,
denkt die sich jetzt grade.
...encouraged Ralph onto the staggered platforms,
although he took his sweet time.
Und hopp!
Ultimately, he just wouldn't jump to the final one,
so you'll have to wait to see him in the bubble dome.
I'll include it in a future video
if either he or Bella sits inside.
Maybe don't get your hopes up.
For now, he went for another climb.
Ah, guck mal!
Er checkt's!
Big brain time!
...and before long, the roof sheets were proving their worth.
Ralph spent much of the day
in his new favorite spot.
I think it's safe to say he's a fan of the
Cathio. And it looked nothing short
of magical at night.
Das heißt doch, aber auch wenn der Typ in den Garten
gehen muss, dann muss er jetzt immer da durch,
oder?
With the evening now drawing to a close, he climbed down
and came indoors to sleep. Satisfied,
tired and incredibly happy.
Ralph and Tom,
they're my favorite...
Aber wie oft gehst du in den Garten? Naja, man muss ja nicht immer in den Garten gehen,
vielleicht muss er auch die Mülltonne rausbringen.
Bei uns ist halt...
Haustür,
Hof, und vom Hof geht's in den Garten
oder eben auf die Straße.
Und ich würd's halt bei uns auch auf die Terrasse,
so als wenn ich sowas mache, würde ich das auch auf die Terrasse machen.
Das heißt, ich müsste jedes Mal da durch.
Aber man macht das im hinteren Teil.
Naja, gut.
So, Leute, ich hab Hunger as fuck.
Ich glaube,
ich werd mich heute ein bisschen früher vom Acker machen.
Neues YouTube-Projekt?
Nee.
Sowas bau ich nicht auf YouTube zusammen.
Ob's jemand gibt, den schaust du dann?
Okay.
Der Frasier.
Ja, ich mach jetzt eine Runde Pepo-Fett.
Pepo-Fett mit Essen.
Ich hab noch Asia-Ente mit Erdnusssoße
übrig.
Gibt's jetzt den Rest.
Was sagst du eigentlich
zu GitHub Co-Pilot? Könntest du dir vorstellen,
dass ein paar Jahre zum Beispiel
statt 10 Uhr noch 5...
Nein.
Glaube ich nicht.
Also, Leute, wir sehen uns. Bis denn.
See you.